all right and we are both live
flashpoint returns he brought to side
missed your man what's going on uh uh
well it's been an interesting couple of
weeks we'll have lots to talk about the
world of destiny keeps changing which
I'm loving the fact that it actually
continues to evolve so much good stuff
going on we got potential nerve changes
to quests the rate is out in the wild
changes to the Dreaming speed and just
the whole grind continues bad rng on my
end but there's like so much you can do
I don't have pain oh yeah mm-hmm
how's your weekend or two I should say
yeah man oh definitely you know it's
been it's been a funny thing because I'm
this is what I know destiny is good like
I'm not getting much sleep every night I
just got to be brutally honest like I am
literally acting for hours because even
though it's a hardcore grind it's
enjoyable to me and I'm having so much
fun with it so you know it's like - I
don't want to stop playing damn bad like
I need to go to bed this is just a
continued downward spiral of lack of
sleep because it's awful because I work
like I'm my early morning shift on
Tuesday then I'll come home do my videos
play for a while then but then I don't
work Wednesday till the evening so I
have to go to sleep but I get up at like
4 o'clock to go to work in the morning
and then I go into sleep la midnight so
I'm up until in 20 hours that day and
then I kind of got a reset go over so
I'm like I kinda I don't quite have your
level of a vampire mind just like my
middle of the week is a mess right now
so but as you said it's with good reason
because I don't want to stop there's
always something to grind there's
another match to play there's always
something to do it's like i cannot
cannot stop and then you can throw
examples up okay so i was that talked
about it it's like you know it's like
you can't stop because also now with the
powerful gear when you see that gold
icon on a map
he's like hold on I didn't do something
no man I got to play through the game
but match alright Paul then you start
getting it then you start combining
goals and bounties and things together I
can knock out these tool if I do this
activity and I could do that it's just
so much it's always like reset is almost
daunting now in a way there's a lot man
it's a lot to do right it's just oh yeah
three game of matches five crucible
matches and restore emissions three
strikes a nightfall that you can do a
little later than you look at dreaming
city tangled bounty is asleep and then
you throw that now with the daily
because you don't want to miss the daily
exactly then you throw that is my big
thing spider because we all know master
Bert cause right now it's hard to get in
these streets oh my god so I yeah I go
respite it when the price of the price
of the drugs go down in America you yak
you're not out of your mind right now I
can get you four tips for 10 cores right
now literally once a day he's like
you're not gonna like an etch-a-sketch
he resets but outside of that you know
you know yeah here raising the prices of
it you buy too much from him so once he
gets out of Charlotte look you're acting
up right now see you at one o'clock
Eastern when you get back to normal when
your prices get back to normal that's
when you know we two more signs one when
you're not getting any sleep
Destiny's good so what it's a full-time
job destinies go yeah when you're
fighting with your friends
yes teas good that's a whole different
topic we'll get in like I'm about to end
friendships on some things like hey
we're friends we not I'm not sure at the
moment where I stand with my friends
alright alright guys
ridiculous interests out of the way
we've got a lot
stuff to talk about the rain has come
out we're gonna discuss what we can I
have not jumped in we'll get to the
other side of what happened with you um
we've got some changes that are
potentially looks like they're coming
towards sleeper in some way yet not sure
ace of spades quest changes in Fusion is
gonna be a topic for sure light level I
do want to bring up as well so we've got
a lot to talk about where do you want to
start because I'm honestly fairly open
man it's so much um I want to get into I
want to get into no I have questions for
you actually cuz I talk to so I wouldn't
get into that I had this brief
discussion when a few of my clan mates
shout out to my man reprinted shy right
now Chris Cobra leader chat the regulars
that's what's up man it's good to see ya
um what it is just like I know it's
early right we all know what only one
week full two weeks in what do we this
is our third and we're on week three of
Forsaken and it's Friday so two and a
half weeks yeah like two and a half
weeks right yeah I had this discussion
at first wood addict and um I had a
couple other couple clan mates and I
need to ask you okay let's start with
DLC forsaken DLC the raid has released
we've gone through the campaign you know
we have you know we still it seems to be
still more to do with the dreamers in
yeah right so we can't say it's complete
but at this point I put a gun in your
head at this point again you know I'm
giving you an excuse and give me the out
that is at this point you can change
your vote at another time ya understand
where do you drink forsaken for in
expansions in expansion expansion to
expand and prior to that what was so
let's just start with prior to that what
was the golden expansion for you taken
King was another question well and now
honestly this pocket this is better it
doesn't feel weird to say that don't
know not know literally as soon as you
jump in you play the story you see what
the rains doing the evolution of the
second tire city that we get the fact
that I can use my Sparrow on both is
just tells you the size of the scales
they have
they the triumphs our thing that's cool
to have it there the lure is actually
stuck in the game
I mean random roles are back in those
were in d1 and we're there but we've
also got quests that they kind of
brought back with taking Kings so things
that weren't taking King we're all there
and then they added so much more
personally on top now is it perfect no
I'd say nine just I mean IG and gave it
a nine and honestly I'd say it's a damn
awesome expansion but perfect no nothing
bones and mostly it's the economy's
really is my issue but overall yeah
freaking awesome yeah man I'm which
doing that and I think again take Kings
that pinnacle for me it's such a a place
it was a triumphant place for me right
and um you know cuz the diehards we
stuck to d1 and we you know we rocked
out Chris Covey's buddies of ever
getting exotics pepperidge farm
remembers I cried a little bit big you
know me but I personally like a meanie
I think oh no no not actually drop them
a cup what I get yeah you've really
excited you never saying only thing now
just wish you know be newer exotics but
that's nothing success on any new stuff
but um yeah it's like I was looking at
and I'm like alright number the time
period I've never taken King that trying
for a moment the destiny fans but they
chest I would say look this is what our
game can become right just how great it
is and I'm playing this thing and I'm
like from the K thing the narrative to
the barons
aldrin it doesn't resolve and you know
you get to the ring which we're gonna
touch and deeper my next question to you
but I'm like already man it's it's bad
it just surpasses it in in a lot of
different forums and in a lot of
different categories and I'm like wow
like it's just a goodbye safe for sake
it is already the greatest that's the
experiencer that gotta say yes I think
it's pretty easy to say that personally
yes question to which was the same the
right for you and don't I know you
haven't jumped in yet you know I was
like I've watched a lot I watched a lot
we've I'm assuming we were both texting
during the whole world's first I believe
oh yeah right that whole thing so from
what you seen
you know I know young play folk from
what you seen and you've seen a lot you
know where is that looking
where's we ranking with that and then
les again a setup question what what did
you have prior as your number one rate
if anything changed by just wanna know
like before because does last wish
change anything and what was your
greatest free before it huh greatest
rate is always torn from me between
vault and Kingsville yes always between
those for me see was cool it was one of
the ones whatever I really kind of
worked on trying to do some stuff like
blinds so it's kind of a really cool
experience
I think the siege engine about where we
got to but generally those were two in
the top and for different reasons the
first console rate it was like the first
time in world Warcraft I did molten core
I mean you got 40 people in there you're
working together you're going through
there's ten bosses in there and
literally you're working for like hours
to take down the first boss because
that's the only one you're equipped
enough to take down so I mean I've come
from that type of background played
stuff off and on where it's bigger
groups going through more difficult
things the fact that two groups finish
this thing I loved it
yeah absolutely love that because I mean
some of it was just mechanics because
the vault for everybody was like I don't
know if the group who got there early it
was like ninja or whoever I don't know
if they guessed and got lucky cuz later
on then people figure it out and kind of
joined them but it is really mechanics
heavy but first off I will say it's not
Leviathan where it's it's a progression
and metal are there checkpoints actually
haven't checked um it's like it was in
the range yes you do two bosses and you
go back in you're still at the same spot
you left yeah cuz I we got to the second
one and we came back jump back into
right at that spot okay so I mean that's
the thing but back to you not like okay
I always have to fight this initial part
blob like so I mean that's the way a
raid should be it should have that
progression the fact that it connected
to this story so well is like okay so
here's this stuff here's the Dreaming
city the whole different world out there
the taken over the things that happened
after the raid was done like all the way
this thing isn't the way the whole force
expansion is incorporated into itself
and the game is a point where it's hard
for me not to and honestly probably the
first time I knocked this thing out the
scale of the boss that I've seen it's Oh
Mike like the teasers when it comes to
the end not quite being done but you
actually like take the heart and there's
we could I back you up just one eye
right at that part
what's up uh we're a team stream did you
listening with the stream that you were
paying attention or why did you listen
would any of them have their background
music on it was kind of depend like if I
was awake or half asleep watching like
it kind of depended I didn't catch like
the voiceover if that's what you're
saying okay I didn't they were like I
was always just watching the fights
never cut the interest and stuff like
bro yeah that part right there where
redeem was doing it apart and I was
homies name I forget glad yeah glad I
got it right okay yeah I'm glad indicus
what's a cool ear arrows before I know
Ravens heart out I literally I was like
what is that beat that is playing like
oh my god it was the most epic tension
aggression I was like this beat is
amazing this track is buddy I literally
googled it I bought the four second
soundtrack that like it was free right
yeah but I had to get it because it came
with a cursor Osiris and um
warmer and and no person was sighs
people hate that DLC does the free would
not come with that no it doesn't oh the
one you get from Bunty roars yeah it's
um it's an exclusive bunny thing the
warm because they never really sold
warmind and curse so I want the whisper
sound that is if I buy it
that's a measly me tell you right now
it's that track that's coming out of on
that joint is that's all you'll be one
of my favorite god there's new tracks of
all time it's ridiculous oh that so
anyway yeah so continue with the heart
and and you were using sites wouldn't
make reference like just kind of the way
it's going you're fighting this beast
that's been taken over the lure of the
Omkar of what
I'm sure bike just lost his mind all of
those pieces and I haven't even not
haven't played it so that's where it's
hard for me to say that it's better than
those raids but from what I can see the
encounters the progression like what
you're fighting you actually have the
techeuns that you're fighting and
dealing with it's in different places
the puzzles that you fight in the middle
of like that second fight you go through
okay here's two waves kill the ads go
over figure out the puzzles go back like
the amount of mechanics that people
wanted it's not just like it's not just
shoot the bosses and I know taking King
up more mechanics vault had some
mechanics but I think it was the first
time but they just they cranked
everything did not even eleven like
eighteen they cranked it way up to a
whole nother level and honestly this
hats off to those guys because I think
by the time I accomplished this one it's
probably gonna be one of the coolest
feelings outside like a world one so
when when the finish finally comes it's
I have a feeling it's probably gonna top
of the chart for me yeah now which yeah
I think you've nailed all the major
points the reason why it's already look
for for me vault is the pinnacle right
and I rate raids different than most
people I rate on encounters yes I rate
on the actual ambiance of the raid and I
rate also I have a different scale I
also rate on the like memorable drops
right now we're the last wish texting to
another level is this is the first way
taking attempted this where they try to
have some type of narrative beginning to
the start of the raid right I feel last
wish is next level like all throughout
the encounter right you're hearing
Morris off you're here you know I'm
saying they're explaining why you have
to do what you have to do you're not
saying it just is constantly narrative
through every section of the rate that
is amazing to me
then Bungie trolls us in the greatest
role ever at being a boss at the end of
a raid right because you you see this in
the all Makara spoilers spoilers
spoilers if you haven't seen it now I
don't know what to tell you but you see
the final boss tour
in this forum or whatever you do what
you got to do the mechanics all that
stuff you mentioned and I'm sitting
there cheering on clear and redeem right
I'm like and they may sit there like the
mechanic is so good with the hot potato
kind of thing right you gotta get it off
boom that person goes to the other room
but and I thought that added so much
tender I think that's why I love that
music so much because I was just like
what are they doing now
likewise you know I thought the rate was
over so that was amazing
then use like you said after the rain
the world changes there's another miss
you learn more was it the right thing
that we did right that's kind of like
the narrative now right yeah exactly
like should we have actually done this
exactly so it's just that cohesion is so
amazing so cuz let's talk about our me
it's my other character category right I
mean the dream is city is one of the
most beautiful destiny set pieces ever
and my opinion really disagree oh it's
amazing
yeah it's it's oh my god this is some
talk in Lord of the Rings game like it's
it's bad right now now I wish you can
make an argument that 10 kings bosses
may be better different things or
whatever whatever these bosses ain't
understands that man you know Kali sure
Oh Chi puzzle you know there's a lot of
things going on here it's communication
based it's hard and I want to get to
that last point too cuz I like I said
getting into it with your clan mates and
stuff but it's all out of love of the
game
you know I'm only first times like oh
damn it's really hard and I'm saying
like this is not easy and part of me
like that part of me was like yeah I
love that Bungie did this because we
were under the we're always under the
impression that yo we didn't do this
raid
you know that that first day we're gonna
get a decent length like the first boss
was what five thirty five or whatever it
was five fifty order
start up 550 or 555 or yes you're
texting me so I'm sitting like really so
this is a true grind now I know some
people shout out to my man zero you know
I don't like it feels artificially
inflated you know he's like oh it feels
like you know says DPS checks but I
disagree them the whole rate is not DPS
checks
I don't feel and um but proving through
you know
Destin's team and all those guys in like
level that they completed that but the
heart of the matter is this is the
endgame activity right the fact that it
was hard you know saying but that that's
but also if you did the mechanics
correctly and not make mistakes which is
hard at a low light level not gonna say
it's not you had a chance to be I'm
saying it's just a complete well-oiled
machine kind of thing so um yeah so you
know you got that going on a difficulty
aspect which I love that they flip this
on your head the ambience I got that and
the encounter is the story I'm like man
I want to still give it um a little bit
more time once I get in there how to
hire like level you know and she was
shut up descending the chalice of heaven
he said he's just made 560 with those
characters can't wait to rage know that
we got that man I'm tell you right now
he said he's efficient that man it's
good like we ran on the first one Callie
and it was so much fun man like just a
little mechanical you know you got a
fight killing eyes cold you play but I
like the jumping in the way in the bull
from the hotel room part figs and people
who ever gonna rape I could tell this is
gonna be a Raider once you power up like
it's gonna be so fun cuz you ain't gonna
have to worry about the tension of you
know dying so much but listen it's early
trying not to get caught out it I've
already in my pain it's already better
than thinking in my opinion what about
what's your top fault for me vault was
one um does it beat vault that's where I
got it
trying to slow myself down I'm trying
I'm trying
cuz vault is special what is special but
I think where I may be leaning give me
another give me another week or two let
things marinate
right once I go through it completely
myself and then you know we finish that
thing ourselves then I will come back
when we visit this time and I will come
back to the definitive answer on where
I'm at but right now last wishes on
vaults neck in my mind it's always not
so good for you there's like quicker
points why is it so good vault is
arguably the most part the perfect rate
I already see one thing vote does may
have a little bit better and I will tell
you why vault is Portland it had the
ambience right going deeper into this
thing finding out it had varied
mechanics you know I remember the first
time you know when the Oracles came up
like what the hell are we supposed to do
I remember the mystery of that the
fights with that the eighth you don't
fight it up jumping puzzles it had a lot
of variety and it was just so well done
in my opinion and it you know what is
something that's the first also there's
always gonna have a nostalgic what I was
gonna say is it more than a soldier
sometimes you it's you it's not just a
nostalgia at first I thought it was and
I went back
remember when a giant came out yeah I
went back to do it the mechanics are saw
a solid man
like the atheon encounter the two teams
in 3d of fighting through time
yo dust me off I can't see what you call
encounter with the eye I can't see you
the Gorgons I read encounters and a
great boss a great boss and his the
strength of a peon sorry macho ambience
is important to me that's one but the
strength of it those drops remember your
first fate bring up remember that vex
mythoclast even the legendaries in vault
were amazing agents epilogue
give me some names help me out come on
give me some names baby singer any
things that belong
what is the damn scout rifle was the
Praetorian foil and this disc outright
would have had the thing ya know you to
pray this was it was it that no praedyth
revenge was the sniper was this type
what was the name vision a conference
yes that one bro those weapons almost
God right like they had some of the
greatest collection of weapons to keep
raiding right so and that's why it had
all these things now the only thing you
can say well last wish I know beats did
that is just with the but that last
which has over it is that narrative
cohesion why are you going near what's
going on you know that kind of thing I
just what I'm worried with last wish is
I'm not saying the weapons are trash I
don't know yet right second with random
roles being in the weapons this probably
the one time why I'm like I don't know
if random roles should have been in the
weapons because I don't necessarily feel
special with the raid weapons but I am
hearing shaloo - um I don't know flute
sound ish somebody just put a video up
um that there are massed work set tiers
set roles of what you call it weapons of
last wish it's like a tier 10 masterwork
drops with like basically set rolls
where you don't even pick those are
they're basically curated versions if
you want those and they're gonna be a
chance mm-hmm yeah shout out this it's
now go into chat aside man thanks for
destiny love man I know that's big for
division got it big oh yes I mean I sit
on my ran I mean I was just thinking
about it
look as it stands right now it's early I
already had it number two I already have
number two and my only number three was
prior to that was um graphic machine cuz
I just feel it's a fun read I just love
the dodgeballs and all that fools it was
a fun way to do play I think right now
it's 10 King has been dethroned last
last wishes at to give me a week let's
find out some more secrets let's let let
me finish the reckon that's nothing you
have to explain right
yeah I was like I gotta get some good
orangey I can't get crap for drops I'll
get like for chess pieces and I'm like
my god
mm-hmm stuff that no that's like I don't
take me a little while at some point I
won't look like because I'm looking at
my boy I'm looking at my boy I'm like
you gotta be careful man I love looking
at what's good fault like you might be
in trouble but I gotta see
I gotta see it's early but it's a fact
that's how good this rate is to me yeah
really is you know so we shall see no
see yes our two cents he sent us saying
when I'm saying no rate has changed the
game world that's a herd of like it's
that's where me this one the whole
cohesion of every single piece of this
expansion and the raid as well what it
does to the outside the feel like you
actually have a progression of what
you're going through you're dealing with
the techeuns that have been taken you're
dealing I don't quite know the story
behind the big s over but you're opening
the vault
you are literally opening the vault so
wouldn't you heads-up spoilers when you
kill Riven you actually take the heart
and don't you take it back to the vault
isn't the whole point I was like this is
a connection of just each piece of the
raid back through has a theme has a
story right I'll try I'm trying like if
you and the soundtrack alone that I
didn't even get to yet is just like holy
crap me like so I mean just the feeling
of start of booting up the raid we're
starting of booting up forsaken you have
the Barents you have older and then he
opens a Pandora's box basically mm-hmm
city and now the taking us out there
expanding more it's just now man that's
I got a feeling I I was like I know the
random roles are gonna be probably one
of the points of contention for the raid
I know you do
definitely this rate was good night but
also you've got mods which didn't exist
you've got the new mods which are gonna
help you as you progress through I don't
know what they're gonna do for prestes
your hard mode but those
transcendent mods or turns into blessing
whatever that thing is that's like
ribbons curse but yes I got one of them
by doing one yep
I have one so it's like those are gonna
be things that are gonna be crucial to
help you with
it just gives purpose to everything
listen what I think if it comes down
like I said I play it I think what you
just said what might be the defining
thing to put to give the championship
over to because there's no great has
never done that this is a oh well you
know one last point but we'll move on I
saw someone oh no please please do
because we haven't talked about
it's going oh shut the Begich edit it
said I have a completed rate yet Andy -
sounds like grow let me tell you right
now
Megatron you're doing stuff with your
service get down a little podcast clean
bro let me tell you right now what we
offer I've said this ad nauseum are you
haven't experienced destiny until you do
rate and it's one of the greatest
cooperative experiences in gaming it's
pure teamwork it's fun and it's always
good to run someone who's never been
before just to run one person through
with a bunch of experts just so they can
get a feel and you have a specific role
it is so man we got back char like I
said y'all you got to get your campaigns
done get your light will show you stuff
but we gotta do that man you have as a
gamer you own destiny you missing out on
the best part but uh yeah back in fact
what you got I think uh I was dealing
off on a tangent our kalasa thought but
um yeah like you said that the cohesive
part of the thing you know the whole
story that may put it over oh I remember
my point now someone on Twitter had
remember when you you kill riff and you
get the heart yeah when one of the
Guardians hold it they was saying that
when that
Guardians timer runs out he's like
inside the heart and you see the
Guardians hand a snap shot it the other
Guardians holding on it on the outside
well if that's actually true I'll look
for that but damn
I will try to get to tweet and I will
send it to you I'm like I was mind no I
mean it makes sense because they like
bigger poof in a drop so it's like all
right where else would they go there I
mean it's not a taken realm and it looks
like it does have that kind of look as
you're inside there on this little like
kind of mini island because his heart is
taking you know yeah yeah and then it's
like when they drive so this is like the
heart's beating slower the heart's
beating faster there's these little
indicators while you're doing that
sequence and it's it's amazingly done
I've never seen anything like it again
I'm just trying to hold out for a deal
just to see where to Rita would I play
it but it's up damn and it's sorry I
just feel sorry for who's working on a
destiny three cuz the Barker just got
raised to a whole new level like
whatever is net like the the annual pass
is not gonna be as big they're gonna
have you know red layers things like
rate layers for this sound gonna be
freaking amazing
yes but whatever is gonna happen in d3
they gonna probably turn around be like
oh crap guys you set the bar so high we
got to do it all over again and shout
out we got to give kudos and respect
with respect is due Scott Taylor what's
it what's the whole meet what's the
other home Steve cotton this is the
second time for me because they did rise
of iron
I'm sure Scott Taylor was on I can
remember think yeah they did rise ran
out I remember when they came out on the
bungee you know show on Twitch I was
like who are these loud I never saw I
was like where's you know cuz prior to
that I had the whole me that did taken
King as the pinnacle what was his deal
it looks mess that's basically because
looking King you did it right and they
need a d2 and did a real wrong don't
know what happened it's not but these
guys and y'all
cotton Swami's name again Scott Taylor
got Taylor and Cotton's buttons you
cotton those two they have now cuz I
love rat emission rat the machine is go
great raid it's just yeah you can't put
it above those other two but it's just
cuz I think length and a couple of many
things but I love the way that rate was
done you know me so this is their second
baby
with last wish and man the boy has been
sick I mean they cranked out a 500 foot
homer and left nothing on the table in
the clutch think about the importance to
write oh I mean it was need to be
pitched a perfect game hit the bottom of
the ninth home run they were behind it
we did flat we lessen the flashpoint one
through four you know 30 us complaining
games dad this was the the the the
quintessential magical comeback on every
level reviewing well doing well like
it's a good time I mean it was on it was
on twitch it was when they were doing
the raid race it was number two look at
look at Wendy's almost two hundred
thousand viewers when the race was going
on May I mean but I was just like whoo
yeah so that was pretty crazy now I do
have a question for you oh so and one of
my buddies brought this up and this is
kind of comes from the it's the sense of
progression that as it relates to the
raid okay
and this is where you're gonna get the
whole hardcore casual I'm gonna piss
some people off in that let's go do you
think you should be able to reach max
light level without ever touching that
raid man as tough and I'm gonna sound
like a snob and I'm saying no I'm with
you that's my whole point as I'm with
you yeah this is listen never what was
the definition of insanity is repeating
the same things and expecting different
results
yeah we just went through the launch of
d2 and I'm getting pissed with a lot of
people the community right now because
they think how quickly we forget
and I just tweeted a post by ready
somebody said I see a lot of complain in
the forum and he's like yo you dudes a
saying is too hard to level up now you
guys it's everything they bitched about
at the launch of d2 I'm saying oh I
don't have time then bro it's not the
game for you or just take your time take
your time yeah like that you know what
it is and I'm so glad you said that
because what it really is is duals want
to have they chest out on day one to say
that they beat the rate
yeah no this is not how it's going down
anymore you're gonna have to and trust
me when I tell you shout out the Attic
you know shout the zero I'm not coming
from because we've had this these
arguments before but like my dudes grind
I grind I've been averaging two hours
three hours sleep cleaning this game and
I wasn't ready and you know what it's
okay I don't have to be the world's
first you know say the idea of the
expansion just launched one week and
people already complaining because I
can't beat it in one week this is too
hard no it's not for you bro I'm sorry
this is not you take you did your thing
and then you get to it but I don't want
I don't want those dark ages of a flash
point number one when we were talking
about the launch of d2 and how
everybody's got everything and how
Hawthorn is given out raid weapons and
how what the rewards are trash and no no
no no don't bring me back to those day I
like where I'm at Bungie ignore the
smoke keep doing what you're doing
I love the new direction continue I know
I mean yeah so like that's the piece of
there's a point where you could be able
to do everything in the game and then
the rate is gonna be the way for you to
get to save from like 575 to 600 that's
your final piece and honestly 25 power
levels not gonna be that big of a deal
for anything you do you're high enough
for anything basically in the game maybe
580 just because I think some of the new
encounters in PvE are 580 so if you were
grinding going through that stuff maybe
580 but those last 20 power levels
they're not that major but you have to
raid to get them there is no question
about it honestly they'd be nice like
because one of my buddies who I was
asking him yesterday he's like he's like
I still think it should be you know and
they'll just say he wasn't kind of tweak
it a little bit we said it's like should
be story to 500 strikes public events
that stuff to 525 or heroics nightfalls
up to 550 and then just have a
progression and that's kind of one piece
that does annoy me a little bit is I
know we have the strikes themselves as a
weekly
activity mm-hmm but they aren't really
tied in to the progression specifically
right and that's one piece I still wish
they would do as you go through the
story give you a reason to run the
strikes be like okay we're going through
here okay these are gonna be your next
piece we're on some public events run
some patrols get yourself up here
okay well strikes are gonna start
dropping Legendary's that help you a
little more this will get you like five
twenty okay and do this stuff a little
more and give you reasons to work
through different activities yeah and
truly make that pinnacle it just would
incorporate a couple more pieces um and
this is again nitpicking but like the
raid should be your only way to reach
max because I mean take world of
warcraft i'll use that as an example
because which is the game i was like we
actually have a support class on a
warlock no so we're networked oh and a
foot in there but if you were not
running the high-end content you
straight-up did not have the highest
gear not gonna happen you might be like
you know you get to like level 100 or
whatever it was like for the expansion
but your gear level the same way we have
gear level would not touch the people
who were like right in that raid they
would run around and then there's also
the pvp side as well they would there
would be the elites in there so just the
fact that you have to fight and work and
the top people have the top stuff it's
just how it should be so I mean again
here's the other thing too that people
forget that the complainers forget its
incentive what do you do when you walk
in a tower and you like yo where did you
get that yeah so here's a question for
you you had reason to run vault for that
reason so that's one of those pieces
like people are still gonna be able to
get up to 600 people are like 589 which
is blowing me away but yeah it's like
you couldn't get to the top without the
rain and some people push back and it
was casual console BS yeah but that was
the only way and that why do you think
people ran that every single angle week
for a long-ass time one of my buddies
had Gjallarhorn
it he had like 80 before I got my first
one he had his whole heavy slot full
because it seemed like as soon as
something dropped and you had a good
chance to get duplicates of it more
frequently but this all just goes back
to thing
being difficult to and the fact that it
was at 5:50 it said recommended 5:50
that's where you start and I remember
telling you before I was like I'm
thinking we're starting married it's
gonna just let it I did that was like
and I won't even for it I was hoping for
that you come to the point and shout out
the iron Lords podcast just because I
was catching and put older one get me
thinking about older games mega man
super boring those suckers are hard you
go play an SES game they are brutal the
exact let me come back later you as you
guys say you have three lives and then
you get to try it all over again when
you're out you're out like the
difficulty in games that I don't have
that much time well then play something
more casual but it's more a challenge if
you want a challenge yes this is a good
game for you because you're going to
have to fight for what you earn you're
gonna have to learn your skill you have
to be on point you can't just be like oh
I just want instant gratification
because they don't care not how this
works anymore and I love it sorry I may
have pissed off all my followers but I
get it it's just - notice we tweet again
what's the definition of insanity right
you can't keep doing what you did in
destiny - to launch and expect the
results to change but you can't we've
seen what happens the casuals get
everything the raids are done everyone's
max right okay I'm ready to play call of
duty now okay I'm ready to play whatever
game and they move on in the game dies
right so can we have little tweaks here
in here sure am i saying like they can't
do anything about certain things you
know maybe you know I'm not saying get
rid of the master work or something like
that you know I know infusion cost a
heart high but hey it makes you make a
tough decision what do I have to infuse
and I'm saying what's the most means the
most to me
same thing like you say with them
dipping their toe in the you know what
our space with the support class is like
do you know how invaluable my warlock
was it was worthless I chose on the
world yes first because I knew I was
getting rain ready I said if I go
offensive I'm not gonna help the team
especially when I got guys like sinister
in my clan who was already he's know
lifing right now shout out their music
hey you know he's like 560 whatever so I
know I'm gonna be like the lowest light
level jumping in I need to help team I
got my mama well I got my blessings I'm
like I'm like 5 o'clock blessings
blessing I got my son my Alma Sun braces
I'm throwing things you know the only
which cause over I'm creating a build
thing about there I'm low-key with the
mods and everything getting my grenades
to charge faster getting my melee to
come back to activate the Sun brace to
perk so I could throw more of those so
loved your names all over the map to try
to control my plate and I'm trying to do
all this stuff under level you know I'm
saying mmm get to the middle with a Cali
fight I get down I thought well
everybody like we had a nice system
though the Warlock through the well down
and was me
everyone did their sleep is there
whispers she did a thing everybody goes
runs for the hotel room the doors closed
all right cool there's all these things
that we had a nova bomb warlock with
skull of Armand Cara right he got it
right back boom he gets his super back
gets all orbs repeat repeat repeat
he was it I was like this is so fun and
then we're communicating who sign is
this you got that the snake sound all
right and me you gotta go over here like
that
first part of the way just like put it
this way people can't even complete just
do the first part get yourself to the
first part yeah that right there that
whole encounter is destiny man
communicating with your friends keeping
each other alive using the right
situations that's why we go crazy for
this game it's one of the greatest
experiences in game console gaming that
was my low caveat it's the greatest
cooperative experience in console game
nothing beats damn I'm sorry
no I mean I agree because I mean it's a
point of like okay doing a point and
shoot stuff over and over it's like
there are times you mindlessly want to
do stuff but if you want to actually use
your brain a little bit communicate
actually have a cohesive plan actually
be like okay this symbols over here I
move over here hit this platform call it
this number from the other side okay you
got this
you're communicating you're talking
you're working together those are some
of the best times you'll ever have in
this game just don't miss them because
they're gonna they're there seriously
whatever raid you do when you accomplish
that the first time when we got to d2
and I got to see the little like which
fired TM as well that baby train the
first time I was like those little
throwback so I was like I remember that
I remember that like just peacefully I
was like so no I mean make it difficult
make it hard May and recommended 5:50
yep that's where you start you can
technically in there into the raid good
job okay it's a little harder well work
on it more you're not gonna finish it
all in the first week and something that
should always be exactly every every
Tuesday you got mad opportunities to get
powerful gear every day there's one
opportunity to get out if you play do it
at your own pace you can get there it's
not impossible just people want
everything instant gratification they
want it now they want their name in
lights
it's not it's not going down like that
unless you put in the work and that's
just how it is all right probably
probably beat a dead horse there a
little bit but I think so yeah no I mean
that's I'm with you man it's like I love
the difficulty I love the way it was set
up the counters are gonna be so much fun
and it just seems like it's gonna be one
of those that dude I know the bar is so
high go or so December the forge the
armory thing no idea I don't know how
it's gonna lately yeah god bless the
what yeah yeah you got me and my dad is
like I'm leaving if nothing is handed to
me there's like 10 to 12 powerful
engrams a week there's probably more
than that now actually because you have
dailies which are small bumps you have
your weekly which are small bumps you
have the nightfall I haven't even done a
hundred thousand yet with axe take a
look a while you've got gambits weekly
you've got a couple ones in the Dreaming
city now you've got there there's so
many so many so
it's just like damn yeah man it's so my
shout out to Hank man your chat he think
they will tell us what the last which
was this year or will they hold on to
that till three this is good question
the vibe I'm getting from them is
they're doing a lot of foreshadowing
right you know when KF decayed Savalas
foreshadows you're after this petra for
sure like what we know maybe we this
wasn't the right thing and then I think
they're going in game you know and I
don't think we get quick resolution just
yet as far as that I think they're
setting things up for future deals yeah
I'm with you on that one day I was like
I don't think we'll see it for a while I
think that might be I don't know if it's
face torito's or what because everybody
kept thinking Sabbath oon was actually
gonna be their loss in this one it
wasn't so I thought you know there's a
huge piece that's still out there so
yeah so what do you want to get into
because I wanted to also talk about the
sleeper or you want to do 12 and then
kind of flow into all that uh your juice
flavor like slippers fine
yeah obviously you know how I feel about
sleepers or Glee my favorite destiny
weapon of all time
love the local of the lore you know the
quest to get it was very very expensive
you know and um I mean not probably not
as hard as d1 cuz do you one has some
really tough steps remember oh shut up
for everything like it was the time
think that you could honestly knock it
out fairly quick yeah you know I'm
saying but he the weird days was like
the seventh of the month the mission
happened in this the cold it was it was
some stuff to a blessing but this this
one is definitely long to in the music
boxes in the lab but anyway I digress
sleep is my favorite weapon hops yeah
I'm very biased on some level with this
because I love this weapon so obviously
in these gambit streets we've been
hearing things though yeah so basically
what's going on now is you know invaders
are coming in they got that sleeper if
they line you up you're done it doesn't
matter I'm saying so you know I I'll be
honest I wasn't experiencing I've not
played a lot of gambit in the beginning
I wasn't experienced in slow mode up I
wasn't experienced in it
you know I'm saying but um I did hear
the outcry everywhere like yo this is
ridiculous you know that I'm just in one
shot across the map and I get it so I
didn't kind of happen to me a couple of
times I'm not okay
I see the frustration now I'm just tell
you what I stand on it our struggle
hearing about a nerf cut asleep and this
is why lore was supposed to be one of
the most powerful things in the game
the weapon is very hard to obtain I
relatively hard to obtain not relatively
hard to explain it's it's up there it's
not I wouldn't say it's whisper level
but as far as obtaining but it's
something you've got to dedicate a lot
of time to get it I feel you know saying
so my thing is this it shot at the
Crisco you saw like still tell what you
girl it's like I'm trying to be balanced
it's not fun when you get sleeper I will
admit but in gambit this is my mentality
like when I hear that alarm go off and
he says invade it ran we're up he's in
your space yeah I'm in defense I'm
hiding behind trees I'm looking at my
map cuz I'm like wait well Caitlyn I
don't want to get caught out there
specially if I got a lot of notes on me
right so to me again now is there times
when you're unlucky and a guy just
spawns next to you okay couey's none you
can do about that right but not to me
mindset like you got sleeper to you know
say like you can do that if you want
things about you know they nerfed I get
nervous not it statement came out from
lunch and he said look we're gonna look
into it addressing it we've seen the
complaints we're gonna make someone just
for something oh boy then the other fear
I had is okay I don't want this
affecting PvE this better be specific to
gambit because do not have you already
personal soft nerf this gun coming in
remember they soft nerf did with a a
little bump little decrease to base
damage but they gave a little increased
to on ammo count okay so he got a soft
earth at the launch of forsake these
snuck it in with the past knows I'm like
I don't like that but i'ma let it right
they gave me more bullets in thing so
all right cool I'm like a nerd in PvE
I'm gonna be pissed
like this is supposed to be a powerful
weapon but when I'm hearing now shout -
Josh Hamrick they was saying um what'd
you call it they were saying that they
right now they're looking at tweaking
the aim-assist you know that it's not as
sticky and you know I'm saying you know
you won't get that kills as fast
whatever but most likely you still good
party I don't know but I'm bringing this
to you like where you at with the whole
sleeper simulant nerf the controversy is
it you know which line of defense are
you wanting I got to talk about it uh so
I mean here's the thread so we'll read
through that real quick so Josh a
Ricky's like he had his sleeper thread
so there were a little pieces monday
said they're looking at it and he came
out sandbox man as mentioned our goal
for sleepers was to make it an awesome
option but not the only option at the
time we're committed to retaining
sleepers full power and we'll be
tweaking full power key word there
tweaking its ease of use instead of
reducing its generous aim-assist values
this means sleeper only made just as
effective in PvE whilst requiring
slightly more skill in PvP case you
didn't hurt tail they are assuming
you're good enough to land your shots
you'll see no difference in behavior
number three we don't expect drastic
behavior differences from this change
but we also don't feel it's that far off
we know their ease the two weeks in like
these wins so they're not trying to nerf
it into the ground
stage one that's good too just as
effective in PvE that was your ask just
take a level in PvP so I mean that's one
of those points where say your invader
do you think it should still kill you in
one shot or do you think maybe it takes
a precision shot for a kill that's what
the argument I was having this are just
shopping demon that's my guy on the clan
you know he made that as his like happy
medium he's like well maybe you know it
shouldn't kill you with a body shot I'm
saying I mean that it requires a head
shot if they did that I guess I wouldn't
be completely against it but I mean this
thing is like a laser from Rasputin like
like you know saying like so it's it
just doesn't sit well with me if I shot
someone what
sleeper that they turn around the
stomach with a sniper rifle you think
they should have anything left either
that doesn't one-shot you exactly well
then no argument like I one-shot you to
the header I one-shot you to the body
take a sniper rifle to the stomach and
then we'll talk tomorrow
oh wait we won't like that's like so the
fact that it doesn't but it takes that
precision is a little more it's like the
charge time is there maybe it's a little
more forgiving I don't know but like the
tweaks that they're trying to do sound
reasonable and not into the ground and I
haven't seen it as abundant now it's
power and melting some of those bosses
is still insane like there's a point in
how powerful it is but generally I think
in PvP as you're saying it some of it is
awareness but also it's like the fact
that it charges up they can see you
through all the walls in the world so
for the invaders it's just like some
thing the farther you are like I don't
know shrink the hitbox a little but if
it grazes marm it doesn't completely get
me if it blows my head off I'm gone but
some little tweak in there because yeah
you're just like you pointed near the
red outline of the person in there so I
mean it's it's a little generous I think
okay I've seen like I mean it's
literally like completely cross map and
like yes cross map oh and that's kind of
thing it has no range fall-off and the
only things the rheostat place maybe
arrange fall off is the thing maybe
which you do that's where you got range
no I'm if you're literally cross map and
sniper that's literally a sniper rifles
job if you had headshot me from there
that's what it's built for what a laser
that far away you got to hold this
shaking thing and trying to ponies which
right now though those pieces maybe
shrink the head bucks or shocks a missus
and give it drop off if it's like across
the map like you think yeah I agree with
that because that person is defenseless
like you know it's doing this I'm what
you did if they did that I got a problem
with it and then long as those changes
don't affect my
PVE and my raid experience is because I
need my sleep everybody needs that's
people don't be you know I hope it
doesn't take it they have to have that
set where it's that against AI and you
know enemies and dis against you know
whatever I believe we have that they
have the tools now to differentiate both
if they do it at Norma I'm the right
with you it's one of those that's I mean
it's out there it's really common same
thing as I hear about Telesto in
competitive but right now it's just
broken oh yeah oh yeah they can catch
that already they softener for that
already
well at least oh no not in a blind well
I'm talking about in competitive PvP I
forget who was talking about it said
it's just like it's everywhere
mmm-hmm no I didn't even know about that
one but yeah and blind well they got
that little patch and I honestly do in
blind weather
well yeah you finish it insanely quickly
but it's not like I've been hurting on
time if you guys are staying alive I
haven't not finished it without Telesto
it was just like people are just pound
through it a little quicker that was all
shout out to esoteric my god that man
oh so load the heroic blind well I'm
like ridiculous really dude dude I was
like I literally I just sent afterwards
I was just like to Bungie I was like can
someone please get this man his own
metal greatest of all time emblem I
don't care I don't know if anyone else
him and Slayer age because those lost
layer age put up his solo of Kali I
don't even understand how that works
either but just those there's a couple
pieces for like the solo guys who can
just pull off feats that I'm just like
and like yeah give him some props too so
shadows of those guys you know so next
question mm-hmm this guy are looking at
a nerf for this heads up I did read bad
but we got to be clear it's not a nerve
to the gun it's a nerf to the questline
that's well I heard that will know the
questline happened that's done right
there talk about a nerf to the gun did
you tell him he knows I didn't know yeah
I thought so I gotta look it up but yeah
Oh problem costume now remember I knew
it was like hey change I saw that and I
told my friend he's like in one match I
had the 18% done I knew about that right
so that piece I know but I really yeah
Paul deci did they seriously nerf the
ace of spades quest I thought and I
could be wrong about what and then I
read what I read was remember when you
got to that point with like the invasion
kills that's the first step right and
then they were like I think they made it
they made something either or so it was
kind of like the effect of um I think I
won't get to it okay I could have sworn
it is one of the patch notes but we'll
definitely get to it but um they
definitely change when it's tough to
give it like an either or option where
you're not require to do that one you
know the precision being in a pattern or
so let me see I think took on all you
have to do is kill enemies now yeah and
it's just any PvE enemy still counts you
get a bigger boost if you kill invaders
with hand cannons yes but you can still
knock it out otherwise and that's one of
those kind of either/or where it's like
okay now I will say like for some people
like my brother he actually finished it
died he honestly doesn't make it was
going to but we knocked it out and he
finished about the same time and I
honestly didn't think he would and when
he did I was like okay this is
technically doable and honestly what the
quest did is make me honestly make me
play differently and kind of literally
now sometimes I literally fur the
complete objective out the window which
i think is kind of one thing that isn't
quite right mm-hmm
I think it would have been nice if it
was on invasion or invading right so you
had to do the invasion so you still had
to go PvP but at least you had the over
shield sometimes right if you got a kill
off on a guy with an over shield cool
that would count as well but the fact
that is just PvE enemies only he seems
like it
it got a lot easier and I absolutely did
and I did it twice and I'm like really
now that's all you got to do yes like my
matches will be done yeah I found it it
somehow fits 2.0 point three point one
so gambit players may now progress the
cage will quote aids will quest step by
defeating either invaders or general
enemies fix it at unease because trying
to kill the invaders where they already
have an over seal and you've got to get
hand cannon that's tough it's it was
brutal brutal that's tough listen I got
it done oh yeah but you know I
understand why people have frustration
with that but you're making make no
mistake they're trying to get more
people to get this got me yeah that was
like my brother's piece on it too is
like this is your preorder bonus you
have an ornament from like literally
logging into the game and like if you're
not great at shooting people in PDP
you're not gonna get this gun that's
there it's like if there was a separate
one that you're like hey this is more of
a PvP thing this is a separate one from
game but so you're really gotta find
where you're gonna work on those
invaders maybe but it was just as it was
tied to this big story weapon that was
kind of like like this is a lower story
PvE weapon and now I gotta go
PvP it so that was like one of those
disconnects for somebody like my brother
and it was kind of the point of either
or is fine and I wish honestly if they
do this it would have been maybe invader
and I was honestly the wording in the
quest text first to pissed everybody off
ya know because it's purple kill invader
and it's like or kill enemies on
invasion or something and it was like
and everybody had to figure out you had
to kill the ones coming in you couldn't
do it on the other side like even if I
do invade and do that that's just more
incentive for people doing it but no the
wording was bad at first but now it's
just like it's it's almost too far but
hopefully I mean with it it's a small
piece and it's like and I did it myself
so I'm like I'm fine but yeah yeah it's
like the third time I do it I'm a hunter
I'll be like yeah this is not gonna take
long
no absolutely not and I will say this I
will say this that um you still gotta
general risk over says it still takes
longer well general right I mean I get
it you know one thing I will say is this
on my point you have a good argument
because people who you know got that
argument you can't even get the gun you
that you got the ornaments created for I
get that and I was it's just like a
travesty if you don't complete that
quest it's so good the last mission oh
my god I literally just muted everything
yes I did the mission over cuz I had
something going on and I was I couldn't
hear that all the you know I'm saying
that the talking and the narrative and
what kraid was talking about and his
will and I'm not gonna spoil that I
still when I'm not you guys got to their
question you haven't gotten the ace of
spades it's a travesty if you haven't
completed because you can't get those
things done so in that respect I get it
you know I'm saying I do like the fact
it was difficult for the guys that did
the old way yeah I'm saying you know
they ain't gonna be no rewards for us
but it's just like a you know our own
little self self trophy what oh yeah man
like get that done because that's how
you send someone off you know and I
really good yeah so yeah I mean the fact
that does open up for more people to at
least see the whole quest line it's a
cool step and like those pieces and I'm
glad more people will see it it's kind
of like more people see in the raid like
this is Lee this is your send-off for
the guy who got killed and you're like
you get teared a little back stories a
little send-offs all the different
pieces and then dude his last one to us
I was like Oh buddy Oh in the field it's
like right in the field it's really good
yes something to say for a lot of people
yeah so more people getting it I guess
that's because I guess I do kind of
forget that too it's like I know it's
like all they nerf the quest it's like
yeah and some people really may be
turned off because not everybody's great
at hand cannons in the first place not
everybody is and it's even harder on
console you know PvP PC it's easier yeah
I will say once I had ace of spades I
had that thing knocked out in like three
matches for my second character when I
used ace of spades and that's why I I'll
have to look and I'll send you a tweet
later if I find the damn thing somewhere
I thought I read there like hey we're
looking into a nerf on Ace of Spades
right now as well but for now more
people who get it can enjoy it it's like
one of those who is either
Dylan or Cosmo or some
about nothing I'm gonna have to look for
it so yeah that's uh kind of a big deal
yeah so we get another piece this one
can I see what other conduct up bungee
is out in the European world so you guys
are out there meeting them they'll be
out just in different places follow them
along you go in here commercials and
does London Underground shout out to him
getting real fabulous if you don't
follow these on Twitter do it do it do
yourself a disservice if you not yeah so
big shout out clean redeem if you guys
don't know more didn't see obviously
they got first and then I forget who was
second and on five dude my heart goes
out to dado and honestly I think that
sweet two is like two minutes off ah I
saw that there's so many little blips
from like taking this one thing whatever
two minutes I'm just like give the guy
the emblem here he at least deserves
that hit fifty thousand people watching
the stream like almost the whole time
yeah man I felt for that I mean did they
have Betty come out any statement on it
but it was a hell of a progression
people were staring at the vault for
like six hours and these I'm like no
sleep and they're getting to the end and
it's just so real and yeah when they got
to the troll and there was one point
they killed it was and that's okay so
here's one thing because this is
literally what caused that of his piece
the shared fate mechanic that in there
or do you want it gone now refresh me
the shared fate that's what I have to
read someone within no it's longer now
but she literally have to res and that
is one of the things I hate no was
talking about it with my buddy and I'll
say my piece now cuz I'm just very sad
please you can't have those clutch
moments anymore the token you can
literally take away from the clutch
moments of okay if one person goes down
I mean the prestige rate literally you
you
used to not be able to read so you had
you stay alive now if you can get to a
res at some point cool but if you can't
in five have you clutch it those were
some of the best moments as well when it
came to reading because you did cross
that finish line being a widget and you
couldn't pull that maybe that one person
who's a little weaker they don't ruin it
and they literally they went through
like he went through Bella they were
shooting on the way down they did the
final phase and literally the animation
took so long they couldn't get run
inside to the heart Weimer killed him
and that was like an hour before he
would have been done yeah no no I mean
you're explaining it correctly and I
forgot all about it honestly so yeah
like I do missed it I missed those
clutch moments many but at one Guardian
left and you know you're right at the
end and all they got to do is a couple
of actions you know saying like they to
me you save those type of mechanics for
prestige mode right yeah normal raid
something if you were gonna like if I
want to pull people into it and like
yeah you might not be a skilled don't
make that stupid mechanic be in there
it's like take it inch prestige maybe
like make the limitation if you die you
don't make it on time you know limited
number of reza's that's fine because you
know a lot of crap going on but that
normal raid that's the only piece is
honestly not because it limits later I
actually get to someone and resum resum
because it's literally the lore of how
our ghosts work yes the other piece is
like but if you don't and you can still
finish it without them you should be
able to know I'm witch on that how much
run and I think what is something that
they changed I think they look they this
is where I think they artificially
trying to make it difficult by adding
that mechanic in it something in like d2
with Leviathan they started but I don't
think it should stay I really think it
should go yeah let's get back to it but
no I'm which on it that's at the point
so that's just one of those pieces just
after I was literally watching him and
he's like oh we're doing the animation
oh and then this shared fate killed him
they're like we got 20 seconds and just
because it takes so long for them to go
in there you have the heart and that's
the finish in the encounter not like the
final stand-in
it was the extra time that literally
caused him an hour and it's like that
Bologna to me is like they did
everything they finished it they did it
with five they did what they had to do
and if you had one person miss one jump
on that like it's an insane run-through
and that little piece that I've seen
towards the end when you like climb
ribbon jumping up all the way it's gonna
be dicey and it's like and that's one of
those like if you don't finish it in
time but you can still get the final
stand off because you have enough damage
that one piece shouldn't ruin your
entire encounter so that's the piece I
don't know if they I'd say fight maybe
prestige as you said or hard but normal
yeah they used to not have it in there
and that was part of the fun so yeah
great guys that's my little piece on
that one but shout out to those guys I
mean it was a 19-hour marathon first
which my eyes would have been like
burning holes in my head at that point
is those guys I know they probably slept
for two days had all the stuff like they
were just I mean bathroom breaks were
probably minimal in there it's just I
don't even their body said and then
shout out to Donnell afterwards pumping
out like six videos just straight
afterwards so he's been he's been on
fire there was even one he said like it
was like Joe Blackburn the senior
designer for the reins were tweeted to
dad as like oh they have to sleep well
it but I mean just a culmination of what
those guys put into it the effort the
encounters and then the viewing it got
the popularity like the difficulty came
so so close like it's so good so feel
good man good to see that stuff out out
to that thing being awesome and I
totally forgot what's up news strike is
amazing
oh it's fire yes Oh looks like Oh
skyboxes artist always still killing but
when you go to the craft you're like oh
this kind of feels holy crap where am I
like that first where like be setting
changes and it's like insta third tech
units the three two are in the raid
where's the third Anna's just like and
just that that piece this is why again
this thing is so because like the raid
like we have a new strike
your third techie on that council or and
this is the UH so on the connectivity
the law can give you this story arcs
everything going from the beginning
during after it's like this continuous
well-written story you know I mean and
like I said I had calm my my told that
this is where my predicts remember I
told you I got confidence when it came
to the law because of that summit the
myelin games thing the input I'm really
getting on them about everything that
was wrong with prior reads and prior you
know I'm saying like you know narrative
things and characters and they listened
and nailed it
they nailed it like that that's the part
that it's really gonna be hard to take
this thing off the throne because of
those elements like it's so so well done
like you said yeah I was like it opened
up a strike we got a new gambit Mac
which is that thing is gorgeous
yes nice I like it you doing man Oh
straight without listening at the gym
this morning so hey I got mine in this
morning I have asked my work out but I
got through it last night - I get it
that's what says screaming - bill
struggle bus is real sometimes yes sir
yeah how's like just the culmination I
think like this I totally forgot about
the corrupted strike when you played
that thing you're like oh oh it's just
like it and when you want to run the
dreaming city or like oh I was running
out of my brother and a friend of mine
were like what are these portals what
are these worms on the ground what all
this little crap that keep showing up I
was like I'm not even done with this
place yet I was like I've I feel like
I've seen a lot in there still stuff we
don't know there's something and there's
like the whole potentially shadow to
hand is your unknown those are my two
big clump out videos faster than I know
life is possible but something somewhere
potentially is gonna have the wish ender
shooting those little like taking rocks
they're floating on like the one that's
sitting on the waterfall yeah all those
all over the place the ascendant
challenges you don't know you've done
this weeks I have not done this week
I've done the last two
didn't start this one if you're not a
platformer you're gonna hate it
yes and he's already in the chat and say
incognito and jump so I already
expecting the worst least I get to talk
to tall and boy because they have been
vastly different every time
yes I like the second week when you you
know you try to avoid the night you do
the black thing and get to the middle
and then dad well I didn't actually get
to do the first one that wasn't quite
like fast enough to do it but it sounds
like there's gonna be either six weeks
of rotation on those or something yeah
for those of all like eggs or rocks or
whatever those will take and things are
those are gonna be and it's just like
this it just keeps progressing it's like
it's not gonna and they really wanted to
make it a hobby and damn they have held
up there into the bargain so far because
their stuff that like if you grind
really hard you'll get to but there's
other things that you you might be a few
weeks out of so mm huh so I'm just like
I could talk about for sale we were we
were off a week Cognito had to raid oh I
didn't actually I want this on
unofficial verbal if you know that's how
did you how was your raid experience
because I was watching I didn't have a
big tears on my face but how was your
raid experience and how do you think
other people for their first time might
learn something from yours all right
well I enjoyed the race gave an addict
Lord addict was spoiling things he's all
mad he's all of sex we got in raid he's
like it's 560 oh my god it's so hard
you're not gonna be able to do it cuz he
had his heart set on beating this raid
and I get it like we came in there you
jump in you had the narrative going is
how great we get to them first encounter
we starting their arm now here's the
thing though you know I listen we were
under level no doubt but the thing was
we were
actually learning mechanics we were
getting it and I'm like no dude like
don't melt down now because we I think
we legit can pull this off we just gotta
have flawless technique you know I'm
saying everyone's got to do what they
got to do we got it and we gotta help
like it was so bad for me I couldn't
kill my night she was like yo Carly oh
don't worry about it cuz one thing I can
control my plate right the first part of
the character tali-rite experience you
know for those who done it every
Guardian you know they look at the sign
the car sign is fine in the middle of
room like look at these chandeliers you
pick out the snake that you gotta go to
you find thats that circle that on the
outside of where the map is of the
corresponding symbol you sit there you
hold your plate down you got to move on
this plate cuz it's almost like
someone's like a hot plate a fool you
gotta move so you don't get burned then
when she I happens the what you call to
get in the orbiter there the ads are
coming at you all the time and then the
the taking Knights pawns mean I was
handling every diamond well of radiance
I was I was I was fine my problem was
when to take a night game because I was
on the level I really couldn't handle
them by myself and that's how you sleep
her and I didn't want to waste he
because I knew I needed it for the
actual DPS phase of the boss then you go
to the center so our whole thing was you
know we had a couple of strong guys
shout the sin he was doing his job
demon reason certain things and in I was
doing his thing it's just that you know
it was they were well under low so it
was these guys are tough so we gotta
call it out we gotta be hey I need help
I'm over here Nina you know we weren't
doing that we kind of fell apart then we
started we got to learn how the UM I
called the hotel room phase goes so then
when we figured out okay his addict did
the judge say no I don't think when
those ogres come out in the middle yes
that's good you know I'm saying sounds
like all right so we killed the knives
and we realized that allows us to get
into the room you know saying that
protects us from her damaged phase so
what was happening you know they're like
just get down there figuring that out it
was a little bit of a disjointed mess so
we weren't on the same page
communication wise we had a couple
slip-ups but each time and I felt it
normally you know how you play a rating
you're hitting the wall it's just not
happening this wasn't the case the case
was we were under level but we were in
proving each time getting better
understanding the mechanics and then
getting to DPS faith and then I know we
would have got it but you know what that
guy Lord addict wasn't feeling me just
so overwhelmed by the decision to make
the rate so damn hard that he checked
out so you know we had a talk we're all
good now but that's what you know
Destiny's good when friends are fighting
friends are fighting and you're arguing
in that ring because everyone has their
own feeling of how things should be done
and you know it's it's one of those
things it's I still say learning going
into a rape blind is probably some of
the most fun you can have because
everyone's got idea is we're trying to
figure this thing out and it's so cool
when one of the ideas works and
everyone's on page but you gotta
communicate you gotta listen you gotta
be calm it's gonna be stress you know
I'm saying you gotta be wiping a lot but
you gotta figure it out but once you do
that's the match now when you know heads
cleared and we did it the next day or
whatever it was two days we took a day
or two it was fine we got in there we
took about three to four damaged faces
before we killed it but it felt good and
then once you experience it the right
way like man that was a fun encounter
you're nothing like and that was fun
you know I'm looking forward to we're
gonna get back in the or like levels I'm
so much stronger now like I should be
able to handle business in there you
know and my other problem was I didn't
have you really need a good kinetic oh
we need a shoddy but you need a good
second another weapon because those
taking little things they keep
teleporting and it's so annoying because
you can't really get a good DPS beating
on these ads they're very good annoying
ads in that first part of the face so
yeah those that but you know overall we
got to the sec my just to see the
mechanics they look cool you know
everybody in time we said are we come
back to this kind of thing so we're just
doing each segment piece by piece calm
nice and easy
have fun road of advice don't stress
don't attack your teammates talk with
friends that's the raid you don't have
to get a championship belt this first
day even though you want it get the
letter jacket even though you want it I
think that's what his Bungie puts those
things out there
everyone gets into that pressure mode
not to just have fun usually inside of
the jacket has the rate I'm one I'm like
I don't even know if I get honestly just
if I wearing that thing in public but
that if they ever put that out I am
buying that don't think you're gonna get
that chance yeah so I mean that's got
one of those it's like if you've done
anything to that counter but that's
literally the way a world raid works
like World of Warcraft you we you
literally work on that first boss and
then you might see what the second ones
like the next week you come back you
work on that boss and more people get
leveled up and you'd have certain people
who'd be like your higher DPS or your
tanks or your main healers like certain
people that start to kind of develop
into their roles and you know the ones
who are higher levels as you said sins
putting out the DPS so you're holding
that yeah it's like and you start to
kind of establish normal places in your
group and you've got roles and stuff
like that but it was so that was kind of
one of those pieces that I wish the
whole token mechanic would go away for
at least normally because then if you
need to be like hey I got a switch on
the fly something's up and you mean you
can adapt you can be that like six on
one oh five seventy through a couple red
pieces so they can see some of it now
there is something I need to comment on
because it ought to be accurate
apparently I was told when we did it the
second time that there's one Guardian
has chosen that has an unlimited token
mechanic and yes so I don't know it is
true I've confirmed this we were doing
the raid the second time the callee
phase and I remember Denny was like yo
don't pick anybody else you're gonna
waste your token and there's one person
that can pick somebody help me out here
cuz you're in a chat you know what I'm
talking about cuz I did it with you
there was a guy who's running with so
apparently the Gator know if it's the
game or something that you do designates
one guardian in that McCowan encounter
to have unlimited pickups because I seen
it and actually guy kept picking he's
like cuz I was like I'm gonna go get you
know this one that died did and then the
guy that had the Macan was like no no no
I
I'll pick up everybody and he was doing
it anybody that went down he picked up
that's interesting yeah so at this
random ER time you started or once you
like understand itself in the room I'm
gonna say it
like it was random blend again sin gotta
help me out here cuz since it was in
that rain would be you know I never had
I didn't understand what they were doing
but all I remember them saying is yo
Cognito do not pick this guy up you go
to the Senate room handle you know thing
I'll handle your night and I'll pick up
the guy that's down but I'm like wait a
minute didn't you pick maybe like no
he's the designated pick up guy what
else in says yeah he doesn't know how it
happens it's it's confirmed it's in the
game we had one guy don't know if it's a
glitch but there's there's a dedicated
person that / you know Kali phase for
the whole race until you all wipe that
can pick up Guardians unlimited so I
hope maybe they do that the only since
says it's random yeah so it is okay so
yeah but it's true it's confirmed
because we were like whoa that helped us
a ton well yeah man maybe they can do
that and I'm saying maybe if they imply
some type of random and give some type
of proper indicated if you have this
ball for whatever it's called you know
that allows you to do it too you know
for future rates featuring doubters I'm
trying to read about it real quick okay
yeah yeah man I was shocked I was like
wow I didn't noticed and it really
helped because that one person was the
designated like healer pick up in
control and stuff when things got out of
control and I and everybody can help
each other out a little bit more it was
really good okay well we have talked a
lot about the raid we have covered
sleeper which hopefully old sound like
it's not covered and liberated into the
ground ASA spades yes sir
tweaking um trying to think what else
cuz I know is we have two weeks often
has been most basically like except the
launch week just like the progression
since then I like what else is you
outside of the raid like what else have
you know what's kind of a cool thing
that you've seen in dreaming city so far
um dreaming city like I've been messing
around with the blind well a lot you
know I've been doing that I was trying
to get my I liked a lot a lot it's um no
I'm rest in peace to last though they
were making it super easy with that
Telesto cheese
but uh we got they got that patch there
you know this week yesterday whatever
was but um now I do love the mechanic I
love arm again it's court of Oryx you
know meets a little escalation well not
not shouldn't say asked this escalation
protocol gets crazy I was doing that
like recently again just to compare and
it's a nice is such a bigger scale and
more of the bosses and all of that but
this is a tighter knit thing it's kind
of like to me all cons Forge and quarter
Forex matter baby yeah see that's that
kind of thing so drop right on the token
seems easy because I'm literally stacked
on those right now I can't right now
yeah which is how it should be because
like that was the reason are cons for it
suck nobody could ever get tokens mm-hmm
yeah great so I like that I like the
little tincture of oil mechanics like
you got a drink a little drink then you
can send it round when you go inside the
portal and I like that I love to tell
everyone on the tincture by the way only
drink that when you're in the activity
you want to be in if you're gonna do if
it's like hey you need to do the corrupt
and strike well ascended wait till you
get in there then drink it because you
can go back to orbit you fast travel
lose it so don't waste that those things
aren't cheap yeah and they put in this
yet for whatever reason I have unlock on
lucky drop rates getting one of them so
yeah that luckily I didn't make that
mistake and stuff like that but it was
cool pick up your brittle trees you'll
want them I just like this I just feel
like it's such an interesting space and
also I like that the enemies are
powerful like you will die out there
yeah it will mess you especially you go
wandering towards the garden area yes
man that place is you're like why am i
oh they're whooping my butt that's why
yeah exactly just working me down yeah
but honestly I mean I've been in a dream
city but I still don't know another
stuff man I mean you know I might chases
for my milestones and touching crust up
and touching crucible obviously banners
this week getting into the head and I'm
I said to stuff like that and right now
I think I'm more into the minutiae so
you'd be proud of me I'm into the
minutiae of customizing my armor sets
right now oh there I know you what which
is a parades or perks are builds um
absent perks builds the park
it's been all that it's been built for
my arm what you call it my well radiance
the that one um getting super fast um
build for my son braces so that I'm
getting melee stuff back so I can
activate the thing again build for the
guns you know some of my best guns Matt
trying to master work tear them up to up
to ten but I got like up to two sevens
here eight you know doing that kind of
stuff mess all you know just one more
fun little mechanic I'm having right now
and I'm fun
boss spec like boss PEC major spec -
yeah I've been putting like boss back on
heavies only make sense and I'm saying
boom you know you're gonna do DPS to the
boss I say you're now using your sleep
and you want to use something else you
know using your whisper you wanna use
something else boss spec on rocket
launch stuff like that trying to know
comparing rolls oh man
you know getting that never end never
like it it's so much minutia and that's
that also adds to the depth of the game
because it's like I got my goal I got
this gold figure cuz I first got to go
figure that head like oh we gotta
compare cuz I got a good one too yeah I
first let me tell you what I thought was
my god oh I got um rampage and I think
head secret not my oh I'm ready you know
I'm saying like and it was good for PvE
he don't get me wrong but I had one that
to be almost sure it was moving target I
get this it was moving target and full
auto right wanna go figure I'm just
gonna try this gun out I was like I got
full auto and Zen moment so overall I
did that and then when I put on the gold
figure with head you know whatever the
other one I told you about with a
rampage and by so slow it doesn't feel
the same like I'm components and I'm
like yes two times but man it feels like
it's close it doesn't to tell but it is
like you're dpsing so fast if you got
them lined up is like burst and you're
gone like that next bullet it's done
and I'm like man I feel like I'm
cheating right his name is so sticky cuz
I got a moving target one time you got
Zenvo so I know you're you got photos in
photos then oh man I was like this works
like real nice and people with all
lighting them up yeah so right now you
don't mess with my bill and now here's
the problem I do have in Discovery with
all of this it is hard to get escalation
shaken out of my second there my energy
spot I see I don't have that thing yet
or Brawl gonna say is it this week or
not is it it's all this week this week
bro let me it's it's all right
everybody in there other brothers mother
everyone uses it believe me I know take
it out of that spot and PvP it's amazing
it's got distance it's quit firing and
I'm saying you know what that trench
barrel do I mean it's got perfect
synergy because remember with my warlock
running son braces I'm slapping the boss
or slapping ad
doing that today right did of getting
the trench barrel pro gets that shoot
off on the on on the on the boss right
before major DPS then I can throw it
already activated the Sun bracelet perk
don't want mad so illuminates I was I
had so many grenades on Kali during out
I can only imagine my clan mates were
like dude I can't see her
I have heard whispers not the greatest
thing on her cuz she lay low Betty this
she moves a little bit that's why sleep
is BAE like sleep I'm never getting my
sleep that's just so far so so first
well I have you said you ain't even up
close you shoot at the floor get out
multiple anything you want to do sleep
is doing man I just I kiss my gun that's
like the galley that's tomorrow
that's been that was my galley when
galley was out indeed one I've always
been slight sleeping way better than gal
always been asleep a guy I wanted to ask
you as well
oh yes screams and the claw the wolf
that pulse rifle Oh No
yeah he's got another one I got was
another one Oh misfit Auto I got a good
one another one you know there's so many
guns and that way you know what's good
about the crew school right now so many
things are viable oh there's a lot like
man I honestly like people are like how
you gonna put boats into a fantasy magic
like fantasy dude poser crispy that's
the best way I can describe them it's
just think and it's just like it's too
and now it's like you're not gonna get
that like instant kill you're gonna have
to work them down you might have to wait
till they peak again but you get both
you get somebody who's slightly open
yeah they got quick yeah absolutely yeah
being violent killer I love it yeah then
you get explosive or hey Brown with the
arm with rampage I'm seeing people with
bows with that bows are a probably
everything is viable Masum jeez feel
good um the the what's called the side
are infesting dynasty was upon us a
couple other side arms that are really
good this really because the time to
kill came down a bit the only thing you
can say that still not good is high
impact scouts yep sorry bro I mean it's
just like pulses or all broad a gambit
that's what I hadn't I'm having fun and
gambit man having a ton of fun you're
the weapons he's giving I tell you
what's my god role now I mean for our PV
for PvE I got to but you got to get this
post called bygones well no kidding
why am I got it yet believe me I want it
but yeah I got that scout um I didn't
get a chance to test it Crisco I know
it's got your mouth you know what
distant relation I have big so yeah I
have a moving target in Zen moment but
it's it's okay it still feels a week
yeah outs to like some guns got decent
sound if
some said alright I swear every Scout I
have sounds like I'm shooting popcorn
like sit there so it feels so weak and
they may hit reasonably hard of like
pick'em range from them but man
sometimes they just they sound like I
know a little more like a little more
bullpup I need a little more posed to be
range and they just don't feel like it
there's what's called the cut above or
something cut something yeah decent
heavy one scout I could if you got a
good role on it
that one's decent but um yeah right now
those gambit weapons the auto I've got
the knee hazard into something um only
thing literally ones here I got done and
I got bygones almost like a God role but
I've got like it's got full auto and
rampage it's it's disgusting I put her
on a major spec on it you know I'm not
like I run down on people in general
with that and also the young the the
rocket they got something one of my boys
demob demon he's got cluster and
tracking track yep I have not been that
lucky minor crap ever the bad omens yeah
yes no my bad omens has garbage sauce
yeah so I got autoloading holster and
quick-draw and I got filled prep in
Genesis yeah Genesis is an interesting
part for some things but yeah like
cluster and tracking haven't seen it on
anything yet it's just really really
really sucking up I did want to ask you
are there any there's a couple exotics
for me and before I say mine for you
are there any exotics you've been
pulling out that have been working
really really well in certain places oh
yeah have I mentioned Sungrazers enough
let me see I've been because I've been
kind of unlucky with now you throw my
weapons or armor I mean either work yeah
I got two I've got two weapons of mine
so I'll save my Inara to be honest
exotic army G has been very bad for me
I've literally gotten
older weapons so my first one was like
risk friend and the second one was like
suros regime third one was like the war
like Chesapeake not anything new
anything so I've been living on some
bracelet on that class and then yes
alright you know what
what old one actually when I finally got
my chaos reach for the UM you know my
comic-con behind right mm-hmm
I grew even though it's for the
stormcaller subclass that right yo that
has tremendous synergy in getting all
your abilities back all the time because
not only are you killing things because
the grenade is it's really good for that
class on the carry class - I forgot
which one is the pulse whatever not the
post the other one that kind of does a
circular thing um it's really good gives
you energy back the attack is like a
ranged melee lightning ball crazy and
then everything kind of just gives you
your super energy back and then on top
of that the natural ability of the class
is when you get multiple kills you'll
see that little lightning energy thing
come back to you to give you recharge
all your skills I don't remember what
those things are called it's got what
they call it's that little force on the
ground it's like a little little you
know tunnel snake or whatever it's doing
it's coming back toward you better catch
it because if you catch it sometimes I'm
in the middle of a crisp ionic trace
ionic trace yes that thing may so that's
synergy
it's just abilities abilities abilities
abilities all the time and did i'm not
even mentioned in putting mods on it
like a super mod uppers is so it's just
i'm in loving this energy there and i
got my third sub class with them the no
warp and i'm learning it I shout out to
demon he told me the biggest advice that
I wasn't using I was literally running
around poofing around the map right you
know just this thing it looks cool it's
fast I'm like ain't really killing that
right so I'm like yeah this is whatever
and I said did the same type play within
crucible I'm like yeah okay so he's like
cog you know if you hold it you explode
and create more damage as a wider radius
and I was like no he took today was over
I was I look for campers I look for
people in the map the cluster up and
then I just tough what's up or boom and
you gotta travel some distance yeah and
it does it does is it's way longer than
stormcaller
it right once you master you just got to
be good with your teleports and getting
out of situations and it's super fast
you like just evil little ghost race
dude it's good as a but what about you
with your classes what about you
classes I have done I've been living
warlock or not warlock Titan missile
yeah I know it may not be the most
efficient thing but I have now had more
fun with a super Thunder crashes so much
fun yes honestly kind of a mini shout
out to when I used it they're not all
perfect moments but when I did the when
I missile is all in the strike in the
face and finish them off that felt
really good
but for guns for me as well go to first
yeah risk runner if it's fallen in
gambit you better use that gun cuz oh my
god it melts really Oh at like a beast
risk runner when it's falling in gambit
if you're gonna go kill ads you can just
wipe the whole side out on your own
because they do so much arc you have art
conductor you never run out of bullets
the arc electricity kills all the ads
dude I will melt an entire set beside
without dying
oh I'm calling that out the fault on
risk collections beast in gambit if you
have fallen now not it's not as powerful
against others because there's not as
much arc now sometimes I'll use it on
the hive because if you let it like one
for all walk up to you and swipe you
then I can go do the same thing to like
every thrall every every like acolyte
and just melt them down
yeah but risk runner gets fallen yeah
that's a must
absolute Mustang game and it's huge now
my other one and these are ones like
I've got a couple exotics to drop them
like with it and I'm master work both of
these so I finished my master work on
risk runner so that one's done nice and
then I finished my master work on
huckleberry and then blind well I don't
stop for me
I like that gun in blind well it makes
sense to oh it's so good because it's
like increased rate of fire and recoil
while you're holding down the trigger
kills with this weapon reload portion
and the master workers reload the full
magazine and doesn't have a page on that
- yeah it's got rampage and ricochet
rounds hmm so I literally just I'll just
stand in the circle wah and every medium
to low guy is just like dead and I just
never Aneta bullets in fire like awesome
you can just hit there and so low the
first part of it on your own like it's
like you pair that up with a shotgun for
some of the big guys oh that's dirty
yeah like he shot he uses escalation
protocol which shot a user I've been
doing badlands I get a reasonable and
amazingly so I got was getting that
escalation protocol I know I had the
hardest time you barely finished in that
I got lucky to find a group of that I
finished that lon mmm-hmm
I think there are only a few rolls
because I've seen a lot of people with
it but my subtle calamity with dragon
play and explosive rounds mm-hmm like
just a combo yeah
explosive rounds and dragon fly so
explosive ahead sorry and dragon fly and
then just get a fiberglass arrow and
natural string the accuracy is 93 damn
yep and I think I got one of those with
draw time on them you get your second
your thir subclasses you second one I've
got so tight and I'm going Sentinel
mm-hmm okay cuz I don't think the fire
one while okay I don't think it's as I
don't know game-changing I should say
not for what you saying laughs it's a
blast
yeah I'll save that one for last warlock
I went straight up Don Blair as well of
radium first and obviously you think
chaos for each will be my second one
yeah Oh stake out yo Bungie chaos reach
bogged when are we fixing it what's up
with a touched it
yeah I mean that the biggest part of the
whole law or lore of the super remember
you supposed to jump in here do you
Dragon Ball Z you know what if no turn
it off early
yeah it's not giving me it's not
stopping the thing so you basically if
you cut her off early like now and you
you must best use the whole thing even
if you're gonna die anyway yeah I
staying up in here to him because when
you cut it off early it's not stopping
at the part you cut it off it's
literally going all the way back to
nothing yeah so yeah please fix that I
want to use this I'm that low key even
though like it's tough man I think chaos
remember how you have that conversation
I mean you like you know just some suits
some classes is just way better there's
no reason to run mm-hmm yeah I'm getting
that way with uh with uh with this
what's goin bro
okay else we're just kicking the other
two plus it's not even close because I
think storm stairs reached that whole
tree has the best warlock neutral game
very close to the well of radiance one
but neutral like or it just pure offense
yeah it's often softens off and then you
get an ionic traces and you're getting
the multi multi kills powerful grenade a
ranged melee like I'm shooting a ball at
you from distance and I'm saying you
know and then you put that with the
right exotics and I still didn't get
those exotic boots that kind of top off
it's supposed to make the super carries
last longer I didn't get that yeah I'm
dying for that so yeah that one it's
like I'm not running of ones just you're
right like Nova Bob still is its place
yes what I'm okay with but chaos streets
same thing and like honestly my normal
fire hammers just due to the rain like
the burning mall is like it feels like
there's so many things you always have
to stay away from in this game yeah it's
hard to get up in that proximity and
unless you just like if you went burning
mall and say it maybe even just against
PvE enemies you would not take quite the
damage could be one of those things that
would be easier but it just seems is
like I've got to get up close the
throwing hammer is cute but just like
the pieces behind it don't seem again
it's as powerful so it's like some
aren't as throwing throwing explosive
hammers absolutely still wreck things
yes could you go breaking point smash
throwing that's how so tarik solo and
some of this crap is literally the OL
hammer class yeah the over and over
still has a no the entire Nova class
still has purpose mom dorm plate they
gotta do something top but I still don't
bottom tree don't lay still good still I
was too because you want to be sometimes
you're gonna have to be offense we can
use well for everything but you can but
you know sometimes you want to give your
team you know DPS and I still bumble did
these still decent in the crucible but
yeah I am looking that storm bro and I'm
like still nuts the bottom bottom storm
bro still not strong and still tickle
fingers in PvE and PvP it's better a
little better but I'm not really gonna
pick that I can cross map snipers with
chaos reach like if you clump together
with chaos reach like what's the new map
that came back convergence yeah in the
crucible Mike was heaven oh I presume
fear don't pack up and try to sit in and
perch cuz if I have chaos reach your
auditor it's blinding huge beam it's
like damn if you melt it so yeah in
charge yeah pretty much yeah by the way
played brush you're not getting out of
the way of that one you're just gonna
die
that thing is lethal I'm so happy for
y'all because that was what mama got
sinister that's what shot the Fonz and
those nay that made my hunter means and
they always complain y'all we don't got
enough and that's like a no Ibaka shut
that we don't have that better power
lutely what that is oh my god it's so
fast you
oh you if I think I've dodged one of
those cuz I was literally passing on
either side of a hallway and I think I
took like I like the it skimmed my butt
and I took a little damage but literally
every other time you're like you're dead
before you even see the super spot you
know what happened
I smile because I said you know we're
hunters needed that hunters need it they
need it to be feared have this and then
the DPS in PvE hate no Jude I was gonna
say it'll unload on some bosses oh it's
like doing more isn't it doing more
correct
you know hunter guy isn't it doing more
than gold didn't come with the
absolutely destroying lots of things so
like I don't see a whole lot of golden
guns I really don't yeah and that's
another point of like if it's better
than Celestia like you might have a
little further range on a boss maybe if
you're doing a single shot but generally
if you can get in a room with one
yeah bleh brush is gonna be absolutely
and saying it really good and then not
hardly seen anyone go whirlwind guard
that is one that I think is gonna be
yeah there's not a there's not a point
where like you know I need to bounce a
lot of stuff back there's not a fool me
it's supposed to have their own the
extra damage after if you don't yeah if
you wreck it a yeah yeah Simon then you
selecting projectiles triples arc
staffed and extra short so I mean if you
got up like a mini boss you're fighting
let him shoot you once with that thing
spin it stop and then just uppercut them
in the face like the uppercut sounds
cool yeah that one's good might like I
will say those spectral blades there's a
few times those things have caught me
off guard among shushing I'm like damn
it I mean if you like are looking down a
hallway yeah you could probably see him
close but in the midst of like a pretty
hectic now fast-paced game the effector
blades having decent purpose if you can
like flank mm-hmm
like just out of nowhere I'm just shut
down I love it yeah I will say a
huckleberry blind well risk runner
Eenie fallin gambit like those are a
must and I got my duty bound by the way
ah
from savathun song and I've heard people
have been getting more of these type of
drops so I feel like the knight solids
have had a little bump a buff
Bob take okay and then one more gun to
shout out the Duke oh they do you know I
got haven't really used I always get in
its infusion material swimming 101 with
light mag outlaw and moving target so oh
wait now correct me if I'm wrong Duke is
that yep that's the 110 hand cannon
oh yes love big hitter mmm so I got mine
with so outlaw hit mark HTS light mag
and moving target and I got I don't even
know I think it's a range perk on it to
Ranger stability so it's pretty
reasonable and that one hits like really
hard to that's actually what I use to
work on my Kate Cain's West because it
because it would hit hard enough it
didn't take as many tasks you need to
jump like to shop yeah done and you can
have a chance to get like take that
shield off and get working on before
they really know what's going on I will
say that Kate's quest
while it would made me completely throw
away the objective and I'm sorry for the
teams I did that - I'm not that terrible
yeah but it really made me like learn
where they spawn yes my ass against the
wall like basically like so the one that
I always picture is a picture is kind of
like the Star Wars trash dumpster it's
got the place is called the slums and
yeah so it looks like that so if you go
up to the right hand side you're up on
the far right and I basically back
myself against the wall and then
multiple times I got kills is when they
would spawn kind of when you are back
there a little closer towards the center
and down that first ramp they would
spawn down there and be shooting I just
walk combined and start picking them off
hmm and then the other one is the first
map we got to play the forest like the e
DZ one the crashed cabal ship if you
walk all the way up on the top of the
ship stand up on the very tail you have
some height and if they spawn there are
they're gonna be across the map and you
can look for him or they're literally
down in front of you
mmm a spot on the beach and you're above
them and they can't see you okay those
were and that was getting the kills was
really frustrating cuz Sleeper pissed me
off like a lot of people it did but it
made me literally completely go out of
the box and be like alright how we gonna
do this and that was not a bad thing to
us what I'm saying I was like maybe if
it was like one invasion kill not five
because sometimes I got four and I was
stuck on the fifth one for forever but
it feels like maybe one or two more or
give you a couple options or just check
some boxes over time yeah it made you it
made me think out of the box a little
bit I really didn't like that and that's
why I'm a little hard when the sleep
nerve guys because I did that ke bounty
first and I was getting so frustrated I
was getting murdered by invaders right
and I'm like yo I can't I got outside
took crimson I played my distance I
waited I was using the map I was hiding
I was very defensive it made me a better
gambit player to try to kill him so now
when I got whatever weapon I want it
like it's I don't have that fear in that
trepidation because I got so better
because of how to deal with it with that
question that's why I'm a little like
it's a little bit of good in here too
you know I'm saying I know the gun is
you know Opie I'm not saying it's not
now Sam but I'm just saying a lot of it
too is you have to play defensive you
have to play a certain type of a way
when that invader comes in and that's
all I'm saying for guys really give that
a shot too as well yeah well unlike me
my buddy and my friend I don't know if
scream was with me one ate it or not but
if it's like if you're all working on
the same quest just literally back up to
the spawn point if they come at you just
unload handcannon somebody's gonna get a
kill and just work on them together I
think you told me that actually first
you literally just like have three
friends everybody quit hand cannons if
somebody invades backup everybody try
and shoot him hopefully somebody's gonna
get them and you can work through it
together
so I mean a little uh there cuz I would
be like look we don't care about the
objectives like oh he's on my map okay
where's yeah okay cool alright if you
get there I get there we try to get them
you know I'm saying and if one got
killed all right like we literally
wasn't playing gambit the right way we
were playing team get the kills in
gambit
it was gonna kitten kill is what we
would do it oh yeah completely through
the quest objective out of the window
yeah so I do want to say shout out to my
little mini fist of havoc the ballistics
lamp I love that thing absolutely love
that thing and I actually haven't even
tested it out with interminable school
for it but I hear it's like a beast with
that I don't even know if it's changed
but what I'll actually try and do is I
can get the elevation on an invader
do the slam and then I can kill and
punch him because it's strong enough it
won't kill him but I'm usually pretty
close to killing them once I slam like
one or two shots or something like that
so that's a nice way to if you can get
the elevation mini slam because you'll
cover the ground quicker and then at
least kind of it's an even fight once
you
no doubt Oh quick run-through I guess on
the swab we do have a new mode coming
and I like how this while there it's
going to be a competitive mode we
actually all get to play at first
mmm it will be called breakthrough so
speaking of all shooting people in the
face uh so the way this is gonna work
is at the beginning of each round
players will fight to capture a middle
zone basically think of king of the hill
once the zone is captured your team will
deploy a quote breaker not entirely sure
what that is if it's a thing you have to
run over there and something you have to
pick up and run as players work to
deploy the breaker the zone can be
contested resulting in an epic tub
tug-of-war between the teams
once the breaker is captured it will be
used to assault and hack the enemy teams
vault so if you hack the enemy teams
vault you in the round so it's three
rounds definitely objective base but
you've got like a two stage objective so
if you drop the first one you can still
you don't kind of like bunker down and
kind of still pull back potentially
because if they don't do the other piece
in time it sounds interesting what do
you think about this yeah listen it
sounds cool you know I'm going to give
it a shot it's different you know like
hearing new Mo's now didn't correctly
for me didn't you play this I didn't get
a chance to play did you get a chance to
play this I got to play what it wasn't
crucible I was like showdown or what I'm
too old to scorch cannons
I didn't scorched for sure yeah you did
that three matches on the very first one
we're kind of just almost at week on
clash it wasn't a big deal I played that
one first I have not touched this one
yeah this one I have not seen so I'll be
kind of curious on this is and again I
don't always like jump into PvP I'll do
crucible obviously wish this was in both
not just gases because I'm not gonna go
jump in competitive like make another
objective mode because we have to go in
yet I'm gonna control and clash like
give us something more objective base
truly where it's like just more variety
and quick play I'd love to see this in
both I kind of hate that it's going into
competitive oh yeah I see what you say I
definitely see what you saying yeah I
mean listen I'm gonna give a shot it
sounds cool you know in theory plays I
mean I just like the fact that they're
still trying to introduce new things
mm-hmm and I'm all for that you know we
all complain oh they're just
an idea is not a given us do stuff to
you know mean we got a gambit we got
this breakthrough you know I I'm really
I really enjoy game I really understand
we can't wait there all right now you
know this breakthrough thing this thing
sounds pretty cool
I don't think so I'm curious to see how
that works you know with the you know
you get control and the breaker and the
tug-of-war seems like this tug-of-war
kind of thing so it's gonna be
interesting to see how you make your
builds around this right we were gonna
come up with some sick builds you know
what subclass is gonna work what better
here all that kind of stuff I like so
yeah like one where more either word of
dawn is gonna be a huge deal
or even the Sentinel wall that you can
walk with like those making different
modes what least give more subclasses
viability which is what we need they
have some cool it could maps to I hope
they're not just for this mode yeah made
I'm specifically for it if they're just
stuck to this one I'm gonna be kind of
bummed out so we've got equinox which is
like kind of a good old I'm trying to
think one with a trials with a nine type
yes yes firebase echo so oh this is the
one they were playing in that was the
one airplane industry yep yeah what that
one so okay I'm hoping these maps come
to other places too because I know their
plane just clash on this one
Citadel just you know anything in the
Dreaming city is gorgeous and then
convergence is back so you got the big
old box in the middle of Pantheon it's
happening
so and then of course see this is what I
talked about like cyberpunk trash
dumpster whatever I don't know what you
want cloud just all it's just rusted out
platforms basically I don't know so but
that was a gambler's ruined so that's
feels for you guys enjoy we basically
have like one we have a map like that
for gambit so enjoy a heads-up gamble
gambit is free again this weekend so if
you got any friends who like have it if
you have a friend to us playstation tell
them to get the game for 143 and you can
keep it
yes and then to you can play game but
for free this weekend that's again it's
no excuse to not decline destiny right
now there's no excuse they give you the
instant give any free weekends oh I
can't wait
the biggest one the big announcement
besides that game is you got coming up
next and I swear I'm looking for it's
double Valor there you go there you go
cuz that is what I need I'm on my grind
do I'm on my register I'm pretty good
man I got the 250 the pulses cuz ma'am I
finally got a good pulse my go figure
yeah working that thing and I'm on step
I'm more like the what you call it wanna
they said to get to heroic I did that I
think I went to the part where I got it
no I'm up to double kill part but I
already know how to get past that cuz I
good old war cliff coil baby oh god yeah
oh yeah honestly like man I will say
grenade launchers are actually finally
viable I'm tagging edge transit and
there's Mountain State which is fine but
I will say in PvP dude just the ammo you
get for a grenade launcher
mhm I will almost take that over a
rocket launcher now because it's so
quick mm I've got some use and the fact
the amount of damage you can dump with a
grenade launcher into a boss if you get
like a melting point melting point a
rally barricade just threw like 10
rounds just straight up especially
something like grenade reserves and
things like that like this is where ammo
builds comes in like oh you can have a
lot I've had I've had I've been holding
like 13 rounds and edge strands that are
something like that if I go look
grenade build that's a lot of damage to
dump out with rally barricade in next in
no time at all
oh yeah and if you had well of radiance
with that that's how people some of the
ways people are melting outside of
slowly yeah absolutely
so yeah double Valor this weekend if you
guys are working on that quest I mean
you're gonna be an iron banner anyway so
get it done that's why I said I'm gonna
knock out my powerful bounties getting
that double vowel at the same time and
working on rhetorics this is a good
rhetorics grind week and yeah got to do
it man I'm definitely on that right
there you guys hear my dog in the
background sorry
here's separation no it's just he's not
so happy when one dog leaves and I'm
sitting here in the office and it's
closed up
and you actually that can actually if
you hear it let me know because no no
you good yeah I got my - saladin wolf
hold on okay seriously just for you guys
let you know how well my dog take this
I'm gonna open the door see that's it
yes
wow wow that's rasa iron right there we
got the soundtrack from rise of iron
live or flash way y'all exclusive that's
literally my intro for adding a big jump
oh there you go just record that sound
effect yeah now yeah one of my husky
unfortunately doesn't like when the
other one leaves without him so he's not
too thrilled with it right now
but so his life but I'm glad you guys
could hear that cuz yeah he's when he's
feeling a load he lets the world know
couple random patch notes iron banner
you guys may have seen your think you
were gonna get powerful gear but they're
not meant to be that way and I'm ok with
that honestly because iron banner should
not be your way to level up and get
frizzy gear you have to bow knees work
through them and outside of that just
enjoy the gear tincture of coins foils
we covered just make sure you're in the
activity it's going away when you leave
it so keep that in mind they
acknowledged edge transit they they had
to know there are too many memes out
there that were great by the way
oh the memes waha yes I saw one recently
I was like literally the full inventory
and the character was made up of edge
transit says yes a Photoshop that turns
it into the full care just like this is
amazing amazing
that's the means of late yeah a lot of
good stuff I haven't watched these
obviously gigs and gigs is it gigs in
glad I feel like those I know they're
not the same but I don't know if they're
in the same clan but either way they're
just they're doing some crazy stuff
because they're up there right now
levels shoutout here's solo right there
good old Slayer age doing his thing
120,000 pop on the boss whatever that is
I'm not sure what that damage number
came from but yeah I mean I work just at
about two hours here guys so it's
probably a reasonable time to wrap this
thing up but yes sir it's I can't stop
playing dude that's nice good man like
again when I'm sitting there trying to
be a reasonable adult and saying look
you've been on this game for over seven
eight hours you need to go to bed
because you have to go to work and then
I say wait a minute if I can get this
one powerful gear doing this then I
that's gonna give me a master work order
is gonna give me this like like it's
this endless thing it just doesn't stop
and then it's it's just it's like a one
more thing syndrome and I got you just
gotta cut yourself off because it's like
you won't stop and because the grind is
what it is and oh so much fun and then
you getting you know the rewards are
great and it's just a good time and
that's this is such a good place it's
good to see everybody playing it again
it is really rocking right now then
dreaming City right now we got more to
do more evolution banners this week free
you know a triple XP free gambit you
know next week is something what's
Tuesday there's something else coming
right through ya breakthroughs coming
those looks like not the calendar up so
you got iron banner this week
breakthrough new crucible maps will be
live hopefully everywhere October we've
got festival Lost coming with some twist
there and then still we've got the
weekly playlist all that stuff the
evolution of the Dreaming city will
continue I don't know how long that's
gonna go how many rotations I was a
bleak cycle but mental to see if the law
was true I remember three weeks but also
feel like somebody said there's uh I'm
trying to remember what they said
somebody was looking at a quest probably
data farmed or something like that in
saying like there are six ascendant
challenges mmm like six weeks of doing
that and there's the little eggs in
there the taking eggs or whatever you
want to call them yes they said there
are a lot of those so like even if you
start that course there might be six
weeks before you finish it finish it
yeah so that's so you got October
November
have a little calmness as the insanity
of every other game in the world is
gonna come out because I'm not gonna
that's one I def which bro I mean I
literally turned it on plays about 20 30
minutes I'm like I could get my grandpa
or that grind like give me more that
grind man is the guy leave my drug it's
back good times good times man yeah so
we got all that stuff coming up and then
December machine heavy machine guns man
I'm still I can't wait to see what those
do to the game I love picking up my clip
of like 20 bullets and you only use them
like Reaper kill and be like here's five
kills come on come at me like I love
that and then we got a new raid lair so
this one's already insane beast mode and
all that stuff coming up in December so
keep it going gambits gonna be hanging
around long enough just when you think
you're getting used to it BAM evolution
in spring so it's it's gonna be a busy
time it's a good time to be a gamer but
it's a bad time to be an adult that's
kind of my rap on that one because I
don't have enough time to play all the
things I want to play and there's too
many things out there now as well oh by
the way did you get a chance to play
blackout Call of Duty I did not my
Boston game you play pubs yes it's take
pub G and polish that that's what that's
what's in Tommy and Mac pub people
people telling me the same thing people
are like yo this thing is coming and you
know I saw a trailer of it you know I'm
saying I got it Sal this is so good yeah
I think it's coming I'm very interested
in seeing that mode and I know with
Activision that budget and now they're
gonna have a better polish you know
that's why I think my pubs you rush to
kind of get out full release finally
because they know you say the storm is
coming you know you got that and
battlefield 1 star right there but I
heard tremendous things about that mode
for us he OD so yes I am definitely
interested in seeing where they go with
that
yeah
I got to dabble in that one a little bit
and I've played pub G enough I know this
is normally but I played pub G enough to
get a feel for I'm never gonna get about
it still coil count like the experience
take the same thing in Polish they
polish the game with cod and you've got
projectiles so it's not neat scan so I
mean actually give us it more yep
vehicles in there I jumped in a
helicopter actually didn't crash up I
got shot at that's guy but I didn't
crash it Oh zombies are a little tiny
piece in there and it just it just felt
like pub G with the Call of Duty polish
and it was like fortnight's free and
it's got its cartoons and building it's
kind of it I'm not - so - will live but
pub G I'm sorry I mean it's like and
sadly it's like I know Xbox went for
that one and then unfortunately call it
ladies multi-platform and Universal and
it has the call of duty name yeah that's
gonna do them but I kick pub G in the
nuts by the time it's done it's pretty
you know going to I mean let's just call
it what it is you know saying so you
know it's directly they got they got the
buzz behind it they got the market it
you know yeah I expect big things from
you so yeah I would not be surprised
it's so that's just I mean that's
another piece Call of Duty Red Dead
Redemption they said the Red Dead on
lines coming in November so much coming
so uh yeah find the time to grind when
you can it's a good time to be a gamer
and I'm just gonna be plastered to my
computer's clothing I think we probably
rambled on enough for this week guys it
has been two hours so thank you guys for
sticking with us chat on both sides have
been awesome I don't I wish we could
have cross chat because we haven't let
go and then you bought this twitch chat
and I need to shove you guys together so
everybody can talk and see everything
but you can always watch this on both
sides you can even just bring up the
chat window and even see each other's at
some point I'll see if we could ever get
across chat together but that'll be a
different animal in itself but yeah
honestly like my giveaway like my
channels been doing good I had one of my
videos pop randomly it was Maya solo
guide which I have to fix by the way we
do a solo guy with whisper of the worm
and then you actually have whisper
warming you using it people are so happy
but I want that mission to get fixed I
know you probably haven't had to go back
in there heavy ammo doesn't drop in
there drop does not drop at all it sucks
so like even with like sparks and stuff
that you got now with like I've matter
Wow
so it's glitch so whatever you run in
there if you go full clip with even if I
go 22 with like a sniper reserves or
something like that that's all the
whisper shots you got now I mean yeah if
you got perfect shots great but if you
gotta go like you can do it with a group
but I haven't tried to solo that thing
again yeah I probably would because now
you can go because the biggest thing is
also it sucks in there so if you switch
say I want to go between sniper if I
want to go special and primary yeah I've
got a primary in the other slot mm-hmm
you can't if your middle slot doesn't
have primary and you don't pick any up
you don't get it you can't pull from
your other primary which is nice yeah
that's probably oh yeah it's like you
got a so I almost need to take a kinetic
sniper for some of the ads different
Scout rifles I can switch between to
drop shields and then go from there
actually bees using that calamity bow in
there though the one with dragonfly and
stuff like that I was wrecking some of
those guys in the middle so it's doable
but it's just like if you miss some of
those shots in the end you're gonna be
hunting and pecking with a scout rifle
so I want I mean heavy emotion final
critiques for me we didn't even get to
master work cause dude we didn't even
talk about that's how crazy get there
that one for next week see if anything
comes up and then but yeah it's the
economy as my issue sometimes the ammo
seems broken or stuff doesn't drop
master workers mod components I don't
really have a way to get those very
often like I had like a 200 mod
components saved so I'll be able to buy
like 20 but once my 20 are done I'm like
yeah it's kind of hard to kind of get
them out you and I have five weapon
parts and they're useless like okay
rolls I can't even buy for five huh I
don't care you get weapon parts all the
time like you can't get mod components
and I haven't modded anything no but you
gotta use them because you would sound
like your master work or game has been
you haven't been see you don't seem to
be lusting like I was so me well I only
have 160 so I'm afraid to use those to
know I guess
it what I've been doing I had to go to
the vault and I was like look your
master worked a lot of things in here
and daddy needs some course so who's
putting their head up for the chopping
block to get broken down for infuse
let's go and I went to conservative guns
I'm like look it's a great gun but now
that I got collections I can get you
back at any time so even though our
masterworks some things I was just like
even even came down with some Master
Agreement wait a minute yeah it's mass
work that's cool but I can literally go
to collections and buy the gun again
right so Russ Miron pressing need
maximum light level with the stuff I
have right now and I had to make tough
choices I'm sorry a ton of my fault but
I went through a good half of it and
once you break down legend did get one
out oh I got it given all my components
like candy or for every breakdown I was
the breaking down a bunch of stuff but
it's like literally once you're done
with that there's no places to earn if
you think you know you're right and
those who didn't have this giant
collection think about the people who
get that's the tough spot it's like we
have some I've got options if I put it
in a PA right and then I'm gonna upgrade
it I'll take it out but it's like I've
had stuff for backups to buy not
everybody has that stuff and that's
right
there should be some way to earn that
literary policy as an article right now
yeah I'm gonna read that once we get
done he says but it's like I'm sure it's
all the same thing it's like you can't
there's no way to earn master workhorse
right now I mean where can you even earn
them from no literally go to the spider
literally I'm a spider has taken all of
my shards because I go to him every day
I reset you all bite one for ten and
that's it I'm not gonna go for more he's
not gonna give me a question he's not
doing it no breaks my will at about once
it gets to 80 oh my god you're not
getting me yeah no I'm gonna hold onto
my shark doesn't use for other stuff I'm
gonna wait I'm literally the day
chipowski every rese every more you know
daily we said alright that's where I'm
at right there like I'm going with it
that's what by legendary chars always
because I'm always won't call cores on
deck and I'm infusing and and it sucks
because my bygones is like a god role
and I'm like man I gave me like a tier
seven or tier six I kind of want to see
what happens when I'm asked is because
it's I can't stop using that gun for PvE
so yeah like I'm like this has to get
master worked at some point because this
is my clearly my best weapon you know
saying like it's not even you know it's
just that that floral that rampage it
just melts and I put a nice little motto
on it man my bygones is a problem like
so I got a master work that Frenchy use
a court here call there when you try any
fusion for armor they want to call here
the car there you know everything's a
core next thing you know you course
again yep that's what I haven't done it
yet because I know I'm not even close to
Mac so it's like I'm not done yeah now
you're smart you probably you're doing
it the right way
me I'm one that I can't like I feel
naked without but miss my role marina I
feel naked without sleeper number one
escalation protocol so your kinetics
you're pretty much you're I can every
every wet those three weapons every time
there's a five to ten light jump bump
cores will be used I'm not going in no
account or that those weapons bro I'm
melting think that's how I was surviving
underleveled because I had the
escalation protocol sorry anybody ran
down let me get out of it trench barrel
get out it distance and he boss from the
yellow bar whatever sleeper get out of
here one of the floor no I'm playing
like I'm playing like the peasants to
get a real experience unlike you dump on
all your saved up materials and all your
exotics I'm the casuals and I'm actually
using your edge transits and stuff like
[Laughter]
but honestly like my power weapon has
been probably whisper I did get it up to
500 but I still haven't been infusing
that one any basically mostly grenade
launchers I finally got a decent rocket
launch your sleepless it's not great but
it's a rocket launcher
like 5:30 oh I got that one yes good
they decent not a great not a great role
- growl - I've been going and it's just
the same way it's like I've just been
honestly playing with what it's given me
like I got a misfit like high impact
reserves and dynamics way reduction like
man devil scope so I've got like man I'm
actually melting people in PvP without
and I know you mentioned it I was like I
finally got a chance to get a decent
role on it so I've been playing with
what's there and honestly I kind of am
enjoying the forced variety cuz it's
play makes a benefit now I was like that
up until about once I hit 500 because I
wanted to read so bad and I was like
yeah well okay I didn't rape you didn't
race you didn't read you know you cannot
come in here with that you can't come in
here with that edge transit and that
misfit those enemies will laugh at you
the light strong but even under low
light with these crazy DPS weapons so it
was a March for me so I think yeah that
definitely contribute to my core
depletion and be going into my falton
and just like taking things out the ATM
and you got a dive in I would have done
it at least then I probably okay but
yeah it's like if I had my set now
dropped like let me do one mod here 1 1
here 1 1 here it was like it was even
the rank and file of how they say rank
and file enemies yes like your red bars
and like just just why do you have to
make it people like oh I don't even know
what that means I'm like yeah cuz Bungie
sometimes is like arbitrarily vague for
no reason but no reason you have like
box I don't even know way to put that
mod in I'm like what you sir what weapon
would I use for that I know what's your
what's your basic killer that'd be a
point where if I'm going I mean okay so
I don't have it on that but say like
huckleberries and just mow down meet
little enemies literally whatever gun
you're gonna use for that what's your
what's your kinetic gun you usually use
is bygones is bygones or the one the the
auto so yeah so if you go shotgun on the
others that might be your your major
spec bygones maybe the other one I mean
something like that but I mean if you
want use those on exotics and I can't
use them on a season 3 weapons so
escalation protocol can't get it can't
get a mod also then bygones your new
special
fancy that's my number one commander's
back in there but see I like what I have
it now I have a major spec because it's
already it rapes minor enemies already
okay so my thing is let me just get this
doubled like I'm killing shielded guys
in yellow bars like we in an orange guys
know I don't know it's like sealing I
don't know where you'd actually put that
thing because yeah I can't find a place
II now I have a great role on a on on
play of the game at PvE paces like
rampage Genesis or something or whatever
I got on it and that really does well
with major spec and I'm like okay you
know you wanna hit a boss you know
whatever you know I found like I just
got I don't know where I'm gonna put I
think I might break my respects down to
be honest I can't find a place for it
right yeah I mean because honestly the
my if you're having issues with minors
and oh you're probably just under
leveled if that's really the struggle so
then when it comes to that actually make
sense because I haven't gotten into
digging that but yeah major and or boss
obviously you got the big boys you want
to do more damage to them or go
targeting for PvP or increase magazine
me what I was like with targeting one or
motmot go figure but I was like just the
little guys I'm like yeah I don't know
that one might might one might hang out
in the vault for a while alright we
gotta let you get to sleep so point yeah
hashtag long point thank you guys for
sticking with us had an awesome one this
week with everybody on both sides of
chat I don't know if I'll ever be able
to smash the chat together but yeah we
do this literally live on both the iron
Lords podcast YouTube channel and twitch
DP so if you bring up both if you're
able to if you're on your phone
obviously that's not an option but if
you're chilling at a computer you can
have both chat windows open and see
what's going on oh yeah we'll be back
next week should be back to normal for a
little while Friday is going to be at
least standard at the moment yes I'm
gonna probably I don't know if I'm gonna
get a nap in two feels like I might need
one with you guys enjoy the grind
for me it's Eve on ttis everywhere there
you are snow alright yeah enjoy notes at
least I said to be like but yeah so
gives you bunches everywhere mm-hmm so
twitch
Twitter and YouTube subscribers keep
going guys thank you I finally broke the
8,000 barrier with the giveaway and then
just the consistent stuff it's been
going on I just want to hit 10,000
that's been my goal for the longest time
10,000 subs so I know the other people
out there making Bank on that stuff but
me I'm just trying to get to ten so
spread the word guys for the love and
shut its iron Lords podcast guys those
guys have awesome fun the leader of all
intros I was literally listen to you do
mooches intro D it's just like dude you
have those written down or and it's like
some of them you knew offhand but it's
like whatever your guest is you do not
feel worthy to this mansion nothing else
the first five minutes of the podcast is
worth every minute but now let's talk
about great stuff they've had some
awesome interviews recently so shout
outs iron Lords podcasts which put him
in your subs put them in your audio
wherever it's at so much appreciated we
have so I have so much fun we have a
ball obviously this Sunday again will be
the Lord's Day no guests this week take
a little break you know it's gonna be
gonna get down with a couple more topics
and break stuff down we got a lot of
PlayStation top it's gonna be fun please
- now and then I believe I won't spoil
the next week yes we'll save that for
next flashpoint but hopefully something
special when you're coming after that
boom yeah man and obviously don't you
know no Twitter at Lord Cognito check us
out there also iron ore podcast men on
YouTube channels here obviously we do
flashpoint here combat talk about other
good stuff and of course the exclusivity
deal with the one-week iron law podcast
episode actually at 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time on the inner circle
network so we put our episodes up there
it'll be up there for a weekend and they
come over to the Isle or podcast channel
after that week so think of it as an
exclusive deal you don't say as far as
access but yeah we would be here at 11
o'clock a.m. Eastern during football
season because a lot of people want to
get their fantasy lineups together so we
gotta respect that even the Lords must
bend the knee to football but yeah one
football season oh we go back to our
normal time which is 1:00 p.m. Eastern
time so check us out 11:00 a.m. they
said Sunday will be the lord's day
that's all I got flash but we're gonna
be back on schedule shout out to the
chat Michelle also three bonzes twitch
check our channel great Chad over there
great guys over there those guys was
Lively
they shout out to eiope chat today
really really good engaging and it felt
good man I missed you missed you guys
let's talk man II having fun talking
destiny its back it's in a good place
life is good right now yeah can't wait
till you get a PC and you got to do it
all over again I'm waiting now PC I'm
gonna drag you into it oh yeah
absolutely absolutely
they got crossbow guess you got me Oh
that'd be nice for a lot of people to
say yeah shoutouts now though yeah PC
yeah it's just how we were all over here
so my Playstations been waiting for
spider-man but unfortunately is still
gonna keep waiting all right guys well
thank you awesome times and yeah we'll
see you next week and hopefully I can go
rescue my dog he's he's a sad face right
now I'm gonna go upside down get the
wolf's will not some help man
All Right see you guys adios jeez